the officer
involved in the shooting of dante wright
has been arrested and charged with
second-degree manslaughter and her
mugshot has already gone around they've
erected barricades around her house
because the far left extremists have
published her address
and when a city manager said this
officer deserves due process a council
member voted to have him removed and
publicly stated it was because i'm
scared
the people will retaliate against me i
respect this man he was doing a great
job
she publicly admitted the city manager
was doing well
but he must be removed otherwise they
would come for her the terrorists
i got to say it in this case they won
now we've got the chauvin trial
and there was some really good news for
the defense the defense medical expert
testified that george floyd's death was
not a homicide because of several
complicating factors
the cause of death would be undetermined
if he were actually giving that
assessment
so i got these two too crazy guys trying
to distract me no we're not distracted
he's trying to ladies and gentlemen in
the joe biden eating bernie girl corner
we have
freedom tunes producer creator comedian
funny guy
sheamus coughlin singer apparently now
uh sheamus cognition of the illinois
boys which we have with us here tonight
sarah from chicago that's right we're
all from chicago area i
i moved out to suburbs and i was pretty
young i can't get that street cred but
this is the joe biden eating a small
child corner
hello my name is jack murphy jack murphy
i've only had a half a beer so far
so we're good 260 today guys yeah jack
murphy live on youtube
no but i was thinking like you know
we've got sheamus jack you know ian's
chilling i'm here lydia's here
and i was like okay but we got sheamus
and jack so i was like how do i
introduce him and then i was like we got
the left corner and the right corner
i was like but we have these art i was
like okay maybe i'll mention the art and
then i realized both pictures are just
joe biden eating a child
so i was like which is fitting perfectly
it is it's a great solid representation
so i was just like
joe biden you guys believe in
adrenochrome oh get out of here
literally eating
this is art from george elixopolis of
creepy horror biden can you see it on
jameis's thing yeah yeah
that's amazing cover it so whenever we
whenever we have whenever we have guests
here because both pictures on both sides
are joe biden eating a child no matter
which side they said and i'm like you're
okay with uh joe biden getting a child
behind you right
everyone says he's never asked me that i
would have been like no
you know get out of here tim get like a
picture of you and i i used to have joe
rogan
on my shoulder over here yeah joe
rogan's gone
well because trump trump's not president
anymore yeah yeah so the the trump ones
we took down and
i was saying i was saying this the whole
time i said this i hope joe biden wins
because then we don't gotta take down
the art you see now all the trump
pictures come down uh i'm kidding i'm so
sweet that
trump and joe biden are just they're
just off in the corner now they're off
in the corner are trump in uh
and joe rogan yeah in the corner now you
know why
you know why jack disc because joe rogan
left us
because because i'm not obsessed with
donald trump all these all these
channels that are obsessed with donald
trump like cnn still talking about it
well like we did on the show the other
day when you will search riot
you got the capital capital trump trump
capital and i'm like
the riots just happened in minnesota and
google's giving me all this trump stuff
they're obsessed i see these youtubers
and they're like what did trump do today
and i'm like i don't know the guy's like
playing golf
there's a riot going on those are the
grifters and apparently in england you
get different google search results too
so it's like they're just targeting what
they think people want to whatever the
moral of the story is use duckduckgo yes
yeah yeah okay well let's let's get into
all of that my friends if you haven't
already go over to go over to
timcast.com become a member
become because we're gonna have a really
fun members only exclusive episode
coming up
later tonight because we got you know
got seamus and jack so you know we try
to keep things family friendly but i
wonder how absurd things will get you
know after the fact
if the pre-show was any indication that
it's going to get right
indication i'm out there swung it jack
it was crazy
dude honestly look every now and again
he's bigger than me but i got the long
arms you know what i mean
i actually queen the pre-show like as
we're warming up we're kind of liking
the cameras ready
i did make a joke about jack brutally
beating sheamus and ian sitting there
going this is cool
it was a joke though i didn't think it
was funny i wasn't laughing
i was just cracking my knuckles first of
all illinois boys stick together
well no we'll fight we'll kill each
other but the second
somebody else says something to you dude
exactly no matter who it is
no matter how wrong you are thank you we
have exactly what it is
where people from ireland get mad when
american born people call themselves
irish and it's like
we're not bragging all right
okay this is admission
black irish we're not bragging all right
all right how about we talk about some
news my friends
i'm kidding if you haven't already you
got to smash the like button you do
because it really helps out
leave a comment just you know let us
know what you think and subscribe to the
show because i believe by
late tonight or tomorrow one million
subscribers beautiful that's right
so excited one million where should they
follow you seamus
thank you jack for asking uh freedom
tunes if you guys want to go to
youtube.com
freedom tunes i release an animated
cartoon once a week sometimes twice a
week i think they're usually pretty
funny we just released one
about jordan peterson that he tweeted
out he enjoyed it he seems to be cool
with it when i make fun of him so that's
really good i didn't think you were
making fun of him at all i think you
were honoring him
in a way so that's making fun of todd
nye coach
yes whoever that is correct yeah i'm
glad you i can actually attempt to
pronunciation i'm far from that i was
like what is it i'm not even going to
try i've only read it in my mind with
disdain
i've never actually said it out loud
with possibilities thank
you coats for making glorious memes
about uh yeah i know it was beautiful
the lobster meme
and that's that's all right so i was
more honoring him but like it's an
impression and i've done things poking
fun at him before and he's really cool
about it i think that says a lot about a
person
oh yeah okay it's funny yeah thank you
you know what his daughter keeps him
sane i love watching those two
she's the one who tweeted it at him
she's like she's like dad you have to
watch this
well i guess you can see them when
they're hanging out and talking he's
like
twisting his mind to be able to
communicate with her without freaking
her out because you can see like when
she was young
she probably said all sorts of stuff and
she's like dad
hold on do you think that he told
michaela that she was a chimpanzee
or some or some approximation best thing
this is why i love george peterson so
much
that is an actual quote it is yeah
people were tweeting me like bro that's
brilliant that summarizes i'm sorry no
no he said that we just watched the
video downstairs in the new green room
at the tim pool estate and condo here
and we were having
some japanese whiskey that was very good
japanese very good
and we were watching up on the giant
screen youtube videos made by sheamus
and
in this amazing video about red skull
there was this incredible line where he
goes
you're just a chimpanzee full of snakes
and i looked at sheamus and i was like
dude that's hilarious joke
he's a jack jack actually looked at me
and said that is the only funny thing
i've ever heard you say
i was like guys you have to watch more
of my videos i was like no we want to
watch something else
jordan peterson actually said that yeah
he did right did he say yeah he's like
this is the only good thing you've ever
made i don't know
the chimpanzee yes that's an actual
quote man he actually said that it was
hysterical
who is he talking about that makes sense
it was during a lecture he's like what
are he's like something approximating a
chimpanzee full of snakes
no it actually makes sense because it's
like you have all these primal instincts
and you're also
full of deception and lies and danger so
context is important so he was talking
it's a chimpanzee full of figurative
snakes figure well i don't actually know
if the snakes were literal or figurative
we have to ask jordan i assume
figuratively but
i hope he meant literal i hope so what
if jordan actually was and he thought
everyone else was what if we got a
gorilla costume and just filled it with
snakes with snakes
it's like two kids in a trench coat but
like a chimpanzee suit full of snakes
trying to buy liquor
oh my god that sounds like a horror
movie shoot them out of your house all
right all right all right how about
you're listening on itunes or spotify
leave us a good review we're going to
give us five stars we're doing that
we're doing the promo
it just turned into us cracking jokes
about which is good too because you know
it's fun
it's gonna be a slow show well now we're
gonna get dirty no
hold on now i feel bad because now we're
gonna talk about like all this very
serious stuff
all right after we're talking we'll make
fun of that too no well not yeah no
there's other there are some some of
these stories are like
very funny so we're going to do a lot of
fun but there is some there's some heavy
stuff up yeah
we have the story where it's like i
guess in california math is racist now
like yeah
that is just i can't wait to dig are we
digging into that now we're gonna go are
you
are you giving them a taste we're giving
them a taste let's talk about this first
story guys let's get serious come on
everybody okay
all right all right all right
now everybody now they're all serious
serious faces
we got the story from cbs news defense
expert found floyd's manner of death to
be
undetermined not homicide it's actually
quite simple and this is a huge
win for the defense granted it's
literally their witness
you combine this with the prosecution's
witnesses
i don't see how you have anything but
extreme doubt like i'm i'm i'm not
reasonably doubting this
i'm doubting this i've been watching the
the derrick chauvin trial
and i watched the state the prosecution
i watched them
plead their case and i heard their
witnesses
they could not tell us definitively how
george floyd died
so think about this for two seconds they
have charged derek chauvin with
murder quite literally saying you
intended to kill this man
and the defense asks how did he kill him
and the and the
state goes well i mean it could have
been a bunch of different ways we're not
entirely sure what we're accusing him of
but we do know that something he did
killed the guy if you if the state can't
tell the jury
here's exactly what he did then how can
i definitively say beyond a reasonable
doubt he killed somebody was that on
cross or
direct it was on uh it was actually it
was actually on direct
so check check this out they didn't prep
with the guy well no no here's the issue
here's the issue
i guess what happened was initially in
the trial the prosecution said the knee
on the neck
cut off flow of like blood to the brain
and then on cross
they were like oh well you know there's
possibly other reasons
so it seems that and i'm getting this
from some of the legal analysis from
lawyers who know more than i
that they switched up their their
assessment saying well maybe it was
because of the pressure on the neck and
back
making it harder for him to breathe the
state actually brought up
different reasons why it may have
occurred the defense
very smart kept poking at the state's
witnesses saying like
man when they got the medical the
medical medical examiner this was huge
the defense says the medical examiner if
you found george floyd in his apartment
how would you think he died and she was
like drug overdose exactly if he had no
drugs in a system
heart disease wow so so like
the left is saying yeah but that's a
hypothetical and it's like dude
the medical examiner is saying that she
could have reasonably concluded had she
not seen the video
it was something else that's called
doubt exactly so then we had
that other big moment where the state's
own witness testified and i i know you
you
guys have heard me say it a lot because
you really got to drive this one home i
really gotta grab this one home
the use of force expert from la said
derek chovin would have been in the
right to tase george floyd the moment he
arrived on scene and he chose not to
and so the defense was like so chauvin
realized he would use a lesser force
option
and that was the state's witness that
said that you expect me to believe
beyond a reasonable doubt chovin
intended to kill floyd
when their own state witness said he
chose lesser force options
i'm sorry dude that's not that's not
doubt they definitively
have proven he did not mean to kill
floyd now we have today's witness
who straight up said it wasn't a
homicide he's a
he's a very prominent medical examiner
he's not from hennepin county he's from
maryland
he's paid to be there by the defense so
take into consideration they ask him
this they say you're paid to be here
just so everyone knows
and he says here's his rate was like 350
an hour and he was like
you've got a heart condition george
floyd's got 90 percent narrowing of like
the prominent blood vessels or whatever
he's got methamphetamine which causes
heart arrhythmia fentanyl which
depresses the respiratory system
and combine that with the restraint you
could not reasonably conclude what
caused the death
he said some would argue being put in
the prone position
was the homicide however taking all of
all the factors into play considering
that you know putting someone in the
proposition isn't going to kill them
i could not say this is a homicide so
this is this is a this is like a
medical examiner legit saying it well
and this is the point it's not even
about
saying directly that no we know for a
fact this is a
not a homicide all you have to do is
establish reasonable doubt as you've
discussed
so people are looking at this like oh
well based on what we saw in the videos
and based on other medical evidence
or whatever they want to tout it appears
as if he was killed okay
but if you can establish a reasonable
doubt that he was not intentionally
murdering him then he can't be charged
with it
but people are going to write if that
doesn't happen people know this is their
minds
that's not second degree right like
third degree and manslaughter aren't
aren't intentional
third degrees out oh i i this is my
opinion i'm not a lawyer
okay legal insurrection has been doing a
really great job with their analysis
because i watch the trial i read the
mainstream media and then i read legal
insurrection
and the reason i say they're doing a
good job is you read them and i think
this is andrew bronke i believe his name
yeah when you read him he's like here's
what the prosecution did well
here's where the defense did really well
the prosecution messed this up this was
good for the prosecution and i'm like
that seems like a fair analysis yeah you
turn the mainstream media and it's like
the defense is a clown rolling around
like dancing
and not actually defending him it's
crazy reading what the left and what the
mainstream press is saying about this
case
because i literally today i'm watching
this
i'm watching the trial live and the
medical examiner said
i would not rule as a homicide it's
undetermined i did not read that
anywhere i listened to the man say it
and i was like wow a medical exam expert
an examiner
who's written apparently written studies
from maryland is here testifying as an
expert saying based on these facts
and he didn't say george floyd died from
drugs or a heart attack he said
he thinks that his heart stopped with
these factors compounding it
can't determine what whether it was you
know it's undetermined and i'm like
that's a fair assessment it's balanced
you see that from legal insurrection you
don't see it from the mainstream media
i'll tell you this though
there will be riots 100 because my
prediction is
first it's possible that because of the
ongoing dante right riots
the jury is terrified and they're going
to be like
i'm saying guilty screw that i didn't
get my house burned down we saw the city
council member
in brooklyn center vote to fire the city
manager
and say publicly i was scared of
retaliation that lady should be fired
removed impeached whatever
and that guy should get his job back
immediately because of vote under duress
yeah
but now what's going to happen is
they're wrapping the defense testimony
tomorrow
defense's case wraps tomorrow friday is
a day off
this is the presumed schedule the
weekend the jury is chilling
and then come monday they get
sequestered for deliberations what's
going to happen this weekend
mass riots dante right mass riots so now
these jurors are going to be sitting
there for the weekend stu and watching
this the city burn to the ground
and you think they're going to come and
vote vote vote not guilty now here's
what i think might happen
they'll come back and they'll say in the
charge of murder in the second degree we
find derek chovan not guilty
stop the presses the journalists route
the door and say chauvin found not
guilty
then they'll say in the murder in the
third degree guilty manslaughter guilty
assault guilty
but as long as they get one headline
that says
derek chauvin found not guilty in murder
you know murder charge in death of
george floyd
it's not the full context but it's
framing that will generate traffic for
the news outlets
you know they're gonna take it and the
activists are going to start
screaming and crying and they're going
to go outside and they're going to burn
the city of the ground
no it's despicable the way the media
behaves is entirely irresponsible and
it's hilarious because for years
they were claiming that the president of
the united states and conservatives were
making them feel unsafe
but then when the country is a powder
gig it seems as if they're doing
everything they possibly can to rile up
tensions even more so
and set the whole thing ablaze that
sounds about right yeah
that's that's the that's pretty much
about kamala harris like in
almost inciting the violence last year
you mean when she was like give me money
to get these people out of jail and back
on this yeah literally
now can you imagine if if trump had
bailed out a single person who rushed
the capital or attacked the capital
that's all we'd be hearing about
i mean we're still we're still here but
it's still kind of all we're hearing
about yeah and he didn't do that
you know we we did this google search
the other day for riots this was like
monday i think
yeah and google shows you capital rights
capital rights capital riots
and you go on duckduckgo and even bing
and you get minnesota
the big one was the hilarious one like
bing is more reliable than google
not like i'm a fan of microsoft not that
but duckduckgo is pretty good
it's remarkable to me that there are
still people in media even youtubers
they put out videos the other day like
what is trump doing i'm like
i don't know yeah it's trump like in
minnesota planning a coup
tim yeah taking the country down is uh
is uh manslaughter considered homicide
yes okay
yeah homicide just means that a person
killed a person it doesn't mean it was
murder it doesn't mean
so this is what happens right they're
like the medical examiner has ruled
george floyd's death the homicide and
then all the activists go
and start screaming because they think
homicide means intentional murder
then what happens is you know in these
cases with cops it'll be all the
homicide because the cop
let's say a cop shoot somebody in
self-defense cops walking down the
street whistling to jaunty tune and the
guy jumps out and says haha kappa i'm
going to kill you so the cop shoots him
first
then the medical examiner says the
person died it was a homicide
the activists say the medical examiner
said it was a murder
why isn't he going to prison because
they don't understand the difference
yeah you get riots well no this is
actually failed state because we have
trials for these kinds of things well
yeah and
we all we all are big fans of the great
philosopher chelsea handler
yes who who in her glowing wisdom said
why are we even having a trial we've all
seen the video
then we had the nation which is the left
in publication saying in a reasonable
society there wouldn't even be a trial
that's what they say about reasonable
societies well they said because he
would take the plea and plead guilty
and i'm like that's not reasonable when
if in this case and it wouldn't it's not
reasonable when anyone else does it i
hate that idea of people just pleading
out because they're scared
there are a lot of innocent people get
locked up they just plead guilty i don't
know at this point i'm starting to think
this guy should just walk clean
he did less than what could have been
done by protocol he did something that
he was trained to do
george floyd looked like he could have
died just standing there
he was saying i can't breathe no i'm
just saying look at the guy
right look at the guy the guy did not
take care of himself how old was he
he was probably on his way to dying
anyway right
well i'm just saying like you just look
at all the factors you look at
everything and you're like you know what
this guy's going to walk in a just
society i'm not i'm not a fan of that
argument because there's a lot of old
people who don't deserve to die when
andrew
i'm not saying he deserved to die but
i'm saying the guy committed a crime he
went through the process
the guy he was less than forceful all
the the protocols that were available to
him
he would that guy showed restraint it's
true children's shoulder
strength hold on let me i want to
address that comment real quick what i
mean is
you said you know george floyd seemed
like he was probably on his way to die
there are a lot of older people that
were in nursing homes that weren't
literally on their way to die and cuomo
still killed them
so 100 100 just because you're older and
firm doesn't mean you deserve to die i
don't know how that came out
you said george floyd was on his way to
die anyway and i'm like
all right but you know when you talk
about the drugs the heart condition the
methamphetamine which is also a
vasoconstrictor
he takes a respiratory depressant he's
got 90 percent constriction in his blood
vessels already that dude was trying to
kill himself
he was killing himself someone else was
on the wheel of a car
yes exact fentanyl and no hand meth
i mean this is the combination of the
two behind the wheel of the car is
it's not about himself it's about the
reckless endangerment to himself and
others
and so the cops they stopped him and
there was even uh the medical examiner
today they showed a picture of floyd
with the thing in his mouth
like he's get when the cop pulls him
over you can see something on his tongue
the judge even said it looked like a
pill in september
and so we asked what does that look like
based on what we've heard already it
looks like he's swallowing pills
right and we know that the state doesn't
actually want to get to the bottom of
this right because if they really want
to get to the bottom of this they would
be giving the drug dealer immunity to
get the real deal to get
him on the stand but they won't exactly
the state could say maurice lester hall
the dealer they could promise him
immunity
you will be immune from prosecution if
you testify and they won't do it
because as soon as this trial is over
they're going to file charges against
him
well as they should which is actually
something that i've been thinking about
in terms of the calculus it's like
we give this guy immunity he can still
go out there and sell drugs
george floyd clearly was on drugs all
these things we've just talked about
maybe they don't want to burn their
powder on that i don't know it's a it's
a thought but like
given the social ramifications the
cultural political ramifications
of the verdict this for the city for the
country
they really should be doing everything
they can to get to the bottom of it but
they're not you know you know what i saw
that i
was uh here's the thing though even if
they were able to come out and
definitively prove that we know for a
fact he odd
uh the officer in question is completely
innocent shoving didn't do anything
wrong
i think there would still be riots of
course there's oh yeah yeah so how much
yeah
right right even if the even if the
facts were a thousand to zero
there's still going to be riots if they
took derek chauvin
after a day after this happened and the
riots were breaking out and they marched
into the top of a pyramid
and grabbed his arms and legs and put
him over the shrine and took a giant axe
they would still riot yeah they would
say we're going to write until the
system changes
they would find a reason but honestly
they might have write it even more when
you give a mob what they want it doesn't
exactly
thinking about like like right doing
nothing right now
is like a fire ablaze that's burning
through the fields and you're not gonna
do anything you're just gonna let it
keep burning
but but putting this pariah in this guy
is like pouring gasoline on the fire
to try and put it out you constantly
reignite the tensions and the story and
exacerbate things
yeah so there's other ways to put out a
fire you know you can burn the land
around the fire you can fix the system
itself so it doesn't continue but
if after this incident they said we will
not be charging any of these officers
you'd have had the same riots they would
have ended and there would be no more
news this year
by charging him he is going to get
acquitted on many of these charges
because they're insane and they're going
to reignite the anger yep
i'll tell you something though i want to
mention this i don't know if the defense
are masters playing 4d even
5d chess maybe they're just slipping on
banana peels
and then pulling off backflips that's
the joke like instead of slipping and
falling down you go whoop land perfectly
do that such people right right so
here's the defense right
the defense brings on this cop who
pulled over floyd in
and he's like let's show the body camera
footage from what happened
and in this body camera footage the cop
is cussing at floyd kind of yelling and
i'm like wow this is like doesn't look
good for this cop yeah george floyd is
like i'm trying man i don't understand
and then that you can hear one of the
other cops yell spit it out spit it out
yep he takes floyd out of the vehicle
crossed him and the body camera foot
stops and i was like
what was the point of watching that then
the prosecution starts
and because he's like no no further
questions the prosecution steps up and
says
did george floyd faint no did he fall
down no did he
did he need to go to the hospital no was
he okay and then they're like
george floyd in this instance you know
was panicking saying i can't breathe but
he didn't die he didn't you know he
wasn't killed
so clearly you know in the same
circumstance he was fine
and that was the setup because the
narrative now
is that the prosecution basically stated
george floyd in the past has feigned
medical emergency
to no ill effect to him it looked like
they were saying that
they tried making the argument see when
he was sick before nothing bad happened
and the defense was like see before he
pretended to be sick too and if nothing
happened why should a cop now
reasonable believe he's being reasonable
in his statements
so it was actually pretty a pretty
interesting you know flip on the
prosecution
that they walked right into watching the
prosecution so far
i'm surprised you you have the these
left-wing outlets can even pretend
they're doing well
they had some good days they've had
they've been actually at the beginning
when they when the judge allowed for a
week of people
to just testify about how horrible it
was to watch like yeah they were doing
decently but then
but so many of their witnesses have said
things that you're like that was a
defense witness right
right right right that's what i'm saying
the prosecution had only i think like
one or two real good days
yeah and and that was just in the last
week on like thursday and friday
where they got the experts to say you
know chauvin killed him
he shouldn't have he shouldn't have used
this force and then on cross from the
defense
they were like eh and it wasn't really
good for the defense and so
some of the analysis is basically that
nelson seems to be tired there's like
multiple prosecutors and only one
you know or one or you know i think one
defense attorney but for the most part
the state's witnesses have constantly
said things where you're like
what introducing doubt on their own
the prosecution it's so bad that you
think that they just didn't even do
prep i've been involved in depositions
in court cases
the lawyers sit down with you for days
they ask you all the questions in the
order they're going to ask you the
questions
they basically give you a flipping
script and then
they have another lawyer cross-examine
you as if they were the the
opposition counsel so either they're
what arrogant they didn't do the prep
they must be it right they just prep or
they don't want shelving to go to jail
because
so the process the prosecution is is is
what's the word when you screw up
the prosecution's throwing the fight i
don't know if they're throwing the fight
i think they just don't have a case that
would be that would be noble
i don't think they're throwing the fight
throw that i mentioned it before like
what if they're actually just
flubbing this but the reality is they're
doing the best they can
there's no case should not have been
charged not at all
manslaughter is the only reasonable
charge in the death of george floyd
only reasonable because it's an argument
about whether or not his training went
he was negligent in his use of force and
he wasn't so he should be acquitted even
on manslaughter
exactly the story is a freaking joke
when this is a scumbag doing scumbag
things
who died doing scumbag things under the
control of a cop doing the cop things
that he was trained to do
maybe maybe but you don't know i mean he
did have his knee on his neck
no no that's what i mean
it's shown that it wasn't on his neck
but it might have also been on his neck
the testimony has shown that the knee
wasn't consistently on the neck and
moved back and forth consistently
which means this is where i guess the
state was forced to change their
argument because without consistent
pressure on the neck
the argument of cutting off blood flow
made no sense because chauvin's knee
moved several times
so daddy okay well here's how he killed
him
if the state can't tell me definitive if
the state came out and said this man
pulled a gun
on video fired it the bullet went the
guy the guy died i'd be like
okay that's their case and i saw the
evidence now they're like we think this
is what killed him
was it was that well actually his knee
moved so it wasn't that but maybe it was
this
bro get your story story straight why
don't you come back after you figured
out exactly what caused this guy to die
giving me a 30-day trial where we argue
about what actually killed the man
if you don't know how do you bring
charges claiming someone did it that's
what's crazy
and again they won't give immunity to
maurice lester hall because
they're probably going to charge him
he's the one who did it right
you know one of the things that bothers
me yes i think you are right uh
is that there's this there's this desire
to win in court like
like it's it's the prosecution versus
the defense and they both want to win
when they what they should both be doing
is getting to the bottom of the
situation
and trying to bring justice regardless
of who was right and who was wrong
if the prosecution finds out that the
guy wasn't guilty
stop the case yes stop you know this is
what really bothers me watching law
order
you guys watch law order yeah in the
criminal justice system yes
the people are represented by two equal
but you know whatever it's different
it's annoying when there have been some
there have been some episodes where they
actually
where uh jack the prosecutor in the og
law order defies the d.a and dropped the
case and like
he purposefully threw a case against
this woman and she she
burned her building down killed her son
and she did it because she was like
suicidal and desperate and her son was
having a seizure and she thought he died
and so he was ordered to get her on
murder charges and he decided to go for
an extreme charge that wouldn't fly that
the jury would not rule on and he defied
her because he knew it wasn't justice
but that's tv in reality the prosecutor
is like i'll say whatever i have to say
to get my case yes
we have politics in play and chauvin
should go to prison for the rest of his
life
even though any reasonable person's
gonna look at this and be like maybe
you need to reform the police department
maybe you should stop training people to
do this
look maybe he was overcharged uh i don't
know the details was that was the person
who decided to charge him the same
person who's prosecuting the case
not really that relevant but there's
multiple prosecutors interesting
question
but like in a in a decent world
without the cultural and political
backdrop
to this case then what's happening is
exactly what we want to have happen
somebody dies cop was involved we do an
investigation and at the end of the day
we're like
cop was fine that's what we want in our
world but the problem is is the cultural
and political backdrop is such
that we know that justice haha isn't
that funny that these people say they're
after justice
if justice prevails well
goodbye minneapolis did you see the
mayor of brooklyn center
it's a city just outside of minneapolis
he came out and called the group
peaceful protesters thank you peaceful
protesters while wearing a ballistic
helmet
i love that that's mostly peaceful
protesters tip
he's wearing a ballistic helmet while
saying thank you peaceful protest
to protect himself from all of the
right-wing patriots who were there
who were throwing grenades and bottles
and beer that's right no no no it wasn't
that he was
he wasn't wearing it because he was
concerned about his his uh about
violence
he was concerned about the celebratory
peace bricks
thrown in celebrations you know you know
it's crazy
so many businesses have just been
blessed by having a peace brick thrown
through their window that's right
beautiful and fires of peace destroying
their people
celebration from from the original uh
george floyd may riots in dc
uh there were decorative bricks yes
whole giant piles of decorative no no no
no no
actual decorative rocks about yay big
decorative
well yeah because they were like they
were fancy right they had like specks in
them and they were different colors
and they filled up all of the flower
planters on the corner of 16th and h
which is right black lives matter plaza
whatever
and i just i've been thinking about this
so much lately
there was just just hordes of people
just picking up these like
half a brick size rock each just
chucking them through the windows of
these big
office buildings they're just shattering
all the glass and peace rocks
were they there before were they painted
no they were like that you could tell
they're like expensive
like somebody paid to decorate these
planters with them but they turned out
they were piece bricks
all right let's let's let's talk about
lady shoving right so the shelving trial
is going on
you know we're we got to talk about the
political ramifications for the jury and
these new riots and what's causing them
we got the story from nbc news
ex-officer kim potter charged with
second-degree manslaughter in dante
wright case
potter a 26 year old 26-year brooklyn
center minnesota police veteran shot and
killed dante wright
during a traffic stop sunday i think at
this point we all know for the most part
what the story is
this guy dante wright had a felony
warrant for aggravated robbery he was at
a party
spent the night woke up approached a
woman who had cash
threatened he flashed his gun at her and
said give me the money and he threatened
her and she
said no they fled she called the cops he
got a warrant they pulled him over for
expired tags
his plates were expired that's a
legitimate stop they they take him out
they cuff him
the cop is on the body camera saying
don't do it don't run don't run
stop stop stop and then he fights jumps
in the car
lady cop pulls out her gun and she yells
taser taser taser they jump out of the
way and she shoots them
and then she goes holy s i just shot him
now she's being charged these extremists
have published her home information her
address
so the cops have built erected
barricades around her house because
they're expecting riots
i guess the challenge here is i mean
what do we even say about this happening
again
another look police shootings will
happen yeah they will always happen
until the police develop you know get
get until we develop telekinesis
you know gloves at the police can just
put their hand up and the person freezes
there's going to be lethal force until
the social worker puts their hand up and
the person freezes
if only there was a licensed clinical
uh social worker there at the scene who
could have just
calmed everyone down you know got that
fella without your feelings just walk
right into jail
yeah the social worker would have seen
dante
and when they said stop don't run they
would have been like
wait a minute stop don't run
i didn't think about it like that or if
there's hand behind his back and they
walk in the squad car and it's all over
exactly that's it or if they really want
to play with his head they like don't
stop
run and he doesn't do it
the cops employ reverse psychology
that's what a degree gets you
no it's sad because
it's sad because obviously this is going
to continue to happen right police
officers have to use lethal force just
given the nature of their line of work
and sometimes it's not going to be
justified and sometimes it is going to
be justified but either way it's going
to be treated by the dominant media
culture as if it's not justified and
these kinds of things are going to
happen we're going to keep burning our
country down
no i'm generally saying like i have no
idea what the solution is i don't know
where we go from here it's frightening
you ever see those videos where they
have uh it's a it's a big gun
and when it fires it's a bunch of
weights in in a circle
with a big net behind it and it spreads
out and it catches
all the pigeons yeah i'm half kidding
but i'm wondering if
uh you know the real solution is i
wouldn't even call reform but a change
in police tactics
and how you deal with a stop like this
so what happened was they got him out of
the car but they were holding him right
next to the driver's seat
so when he ripped away and jumped into
the driver's seat they could have got
him out and immediately pulled him back
and pulled him far back
i know it's easy to be like i wasn't
there but here's what i would have done
but i'm wondering if there's like if we
could look at how police behave
you know instinctively and then come up
with with a simple training plan or
procedure plan
that can put a roadblock in a lot of
these circumstances
like face the guy backwards immediately
you know or or like
put his make his left leg over his right
leg or something like that that could
just
make it very difficult for them to get
the jump on a cop in some way
it's not easy you know yeah cuff their
feet right away there you go there's a
tendency for
people to take advantage of like things
they see that they didn't real like it's
like don't leave your backpack in your
back seat in plain view because if
if someone walks by they're way more
likely to break into your car if they
see something that is so misogynistic of
you to say
dude she can wear whatever dress she
wants wherever she goes at any time boy
that's a good point but don't tempt fate
i guess is the point nope misogyny
this is what's this is what's
interesting about uh what tim just said
too though
i mean there are what four million
police interactions per year
and the number of people killed by
police officers shot by police
police officers is like usually under a
thousand usually
in the hundreds and so it's extremely
rare
and so my point is even if they change
their tactics to minimize the number of
deaths there are still going to be some
deaths
right and there are still going to be
riots as there is takes only one you
know if everybody just took a gd
stats class yeah oh sorry with this i
shortened it up i thought it just it's
totally neutered we know what you're
saying i totally neutered i thought he
crossed himself as i
as i sent me blasphemy exactly it was i
tried to use acronyms
i'm sorry if everybody would just take a
gash darn which is what i meant in the
first place
bro class on statistics
well then maybe we could put all the
stuff in perspective yes
agreed i got a question about this when
she yelled taser taser taser
was she ordering the other cop to fire
their taser
and she was just holding her gun waiting
she hasn't i don't think she said yet
and that's smart but the department said
she
they thought she was intending to use
her taser intending to use her taser but
then grabbed her gun instead
that was stupid because most people look
at this and i think a reasonable person
sees this
here's a guy who's wanted an aggravated
robbery he's been known to have a ruger
45 in the past
he resisted arrest attempted to flee and
then jumped into his car
and they couldn't see what he was
reaching for at that point
shooting him was justified i think so
too
you couldn't see me turned away and he
like looked like he's reaching into the
passenger seat or something and why
exactly i don't understand why what do
they think is going to happen it's like
i'm going to get away from this cop and
then a week later i'll go to jail for
for 10 more years
like what do they think is going to
happen the same thing that leads them to
commit these crimes is the same thing
that leads them to do these dumb things
in the presence of cops
poor impulse control total stupidity
sheer lunacy bad education no father
no community all these systemic issues
well this guy had a dad
he what this guy had a dad well he had a
suck ass dad then apparently
who didn't without no no no no no no i
wasn't i wasn't that wasn't directed at
you that wasn't directed at you i was
just saying a prayer for the guy
oh but i can't say a prayer for him but
at the same time like i'm trying to
acknowledge that this is a systemic
oh no why 100 agree with you right
there's a huge system that breeds
something like this
where somebody doesn't know that you
don't carry gun you don't commit crimes
you don't
commit aggravated assault you don't try
to flee from a cop and you sure as heck
don't put your hand down on the floor
boards when the cop has a gun drawn on
exactly no but nobody understands well
there it's because people make this out
about systemic racism but these are all
things that i
as a very white person would never dream
of getting away with doing in front of a
police officer it's insane
i i we talked about it before why is it
that
if it's about systemic racism i am
taught
as a white person who's apparently in
this white dominance culture and i can
get away with anything
every time the cop comes to my car when
i get pulled over going 100 in the 45
10 and two license and registration in
one hand
yes sir no sir even if he's 19 years old
and a punk
yes or no sir no excuse yes or no sir
yes or no sir
that makes that's i'm white supremacist
why yeah exactly why
so i don't know about you guys we talked
about this before but i i got the talk
when i was
when i was younger you know the talk
yeah there was one here so
so about you know about learning
learning karate and learning
exactly
when i was little my dad said when you
encounter police
here's what you have to do right here's
how you respond you know
when they're at the door here's when you
get pulled over what you got to do turn
the dome light on turn the radio off
stop the car take your keys out put them
on the dash take your wallet your phone
whatever you got put on the dash your
insurance on the dash
hands ten and two and have the window
roll down so when they walk up and they
say license and insurance you go it's
right here officer
and you take it right in front of plane
view and you open it up instead of
reaching in the glove box or reaching i
was told to do that
i don't understand when i see these
commercials there's a commercial they
did where it's like a black father
talking to his kid and it's like
it's time for the talk what you need to
understand about police in this country
and i was like i don't i don't
understand why they don't try to
represent just poor people in general
because i've been through that you were
just saying the exact same thing you
were told the exact same thing that's
how you behave with the police
i'm wondering if you guys were ever told
that when you were little here's how to
behave around cops ian's not yeah well
no
i have i'll let you know what i was told
like do that and i
was like okay i didn't know why and then
someone later told me because
the cop is terrified they don't know if
you have a gun
so they're assuming you have a weapon at
all times if you make jerky movements
they're going to think you're going for
a weapon then it sunk in i was like
that's why
okay yes right yeah so why is it that
i'm told that
why is it that you're told that and then
i act like you were told
all my uncles are police officers or not
all of them but three of my guests you
guys course
exactly i'm a virus chicago area
so of course three of my dad's brothers
became cops nice um
three of my dad's nine brothers his 100
siblings
but no i mean they uh my parents told me
when i was a kid you have to be very
careful when you're interacting with the
police
and they also said this they're like
yeah your uncles are good cops but there
are crooked cops out there they told me
as a kid
don't talk to the police don't even talk
to them when they ask you questions keep
your mouth shut call us
or do they say tell them your uncle's a
cop let's tell your husband sometimes
i i need to do that on my own i had
those street smarts i was like hey you
know when you get a coughlin's out there
or a police officer
he's like oh yeah i used to work with
that guy here there are a lot of tricks
that that people
people do when they have family in the
police department of the fire department
so i would know about that too so
it's it's simple so you're saying is
there a lot of tricks people do if
they're irish
apartment police one heart but it's all
yeah one of the tricks was
uh was uh just uh i'll just say this if
if
you know i was to get pulled over what's
going on sorry i'm trying to rush to the
fire department and meet my dad for
dinner
oh you're good to go hilarious
professional courtesy for the
firefighters who are helping us out
things like that we but no no no joke
the police have the stickers the
firefighters have the stickers
and i've i simply i'll simplify the
story but i've had incident incidents uh
uh instances with police who have pulled
me over and then when they see the
firefighter emblem they're like who's a
firefighter
it's my dad and they're like have a good
day yeah i mean i'll do it again
stick around the back my dad was a
fireman maybe like who's the [ __ ] both
of your dads were firemen yeah yeah
yeah my sister was a fireman okay well i
well guess what my brother is a
paramedic for the fire department so
you're a fire person no yes yes i'm not
sure she
definitely has her pronouns in her
emails now fire person
that's her jaw her core fire fire person
fire women
i meant fireman's fire fire
cops firefighters and don't forget
animations post off postal workers as
well
do they get lighter carriers we
definitely had a bunch of litter
carriers in our family
but if but if you get pulled over and
you tell the cop you're a post office
worker they let you go no i don't think
that works
i think i think the issue is if you're
like ems paramedic fire department cop
it's because they all work together
first yeah i don't i don't yeah first
responders i don't think it's
necessarily about like
professional courtesy in the sense where
it's like oh you work with the fire
department then
it's more like i'm gonna see this guy
later on and we have to have a calm
working relationship
if somebody's a family member of a
firefighter you know and they come they
complain about me or my badge number
then one day i see the guy and there's
pool it's like oh geez i pulled this
guy's kid over
mad at me right but i i have gotten
pulled over i don't carry i don't put
the stickers on the back of my window i
have fire
fire fighters i have police chiefs in
fact
in the family i've got cops we got the
whole thing and
every single time absolutely
yes sir telling the cop that you're in
the family
comes after they're comfortable and they
see your hands in plain view
we had a joke because it was so obvious
what you're talking about
to me anyway once you think about it
that we'd be like maybe like license
registration sure we'd be like
yeah it's right here in my glove
compartment
that's a really bad idea don't ever
actually don't try that one it's a joke
never
ever ever and the next day they go free
climbing so there you go so
like come on guys say perfectly still
assume from the police officer's
perspective and assume that they think
you have a weapon
so now i think we may are minimizing
some instances in which there's actually
been people with their hands up on their
knees getting shot
through the doors but we're just talking
specifically
about auto stops and how you can handle
yourself
in an auto stop with law enforcement
yeah and here's the thing there are
psychopaths in every profession
so of course you're going to have
psychopathic cops or even just people
with
other illnesses which are untreated who
are or who are just plain evil
who who will um conduct themselves in
dangerous ways or even kill people
but let's let's we still want to teach
people how to behave when they're with
and a lot of it is just common sense but
you want to help people understand
like we could minimize the number of
deaths at the hands of police each year
if folks just understood this
let's let's invert the politics because
we had another
officer involved shooting a few months
ago that uh did not result in widespread
rioting and that was ashley babbitt
so we got the story from killed ashley
babbitt we don't know
here's the story prosecutors won't
pursue charges in shooting death of
ashley babbitt during capital riot
long story short they said the officer
didn't understand what's happening she
defied uh repeated commands
the officer was scared he fired he
killed her through a door
through a door he couldn't see her she
wasn't holding anything they were fired
blindly
into a crowd okay justified they said
these are the same people on january 5th
said we don't need any reinforcements
we don't need any extra cops we don't
need any national guard
january january 5th we know all this
stuff is coming we don't need anybody
babbitt's the girl that climbed up in
the capitol building right no she was
standing behind a door
door here she was standing behind the
door and the cop
the capitol uh police shot right through
the door and just killed a woman who was
just standing there okay but this is the
girl i'm thinking of the one that was
the only
person she was murdered and put her head
in the window and they saw a head pop
up and fired wait that's not a chat i'm
sorry seeing someone's face isn't a
threat
i'm sitting here you know are arguing
that
uh in many instances there could have
been an alternative for the cop it's
it's so sad that these these young black
men have lost their lives in
circumstances
it's regrettable and then here you have
a woman who quite literally just peeks
her head through a window and takes a
bolt to the neck
there were cops behind her what like so
if you watch the video
she goes down and immediately a swat
team is right there within like 10 or 15
seconds
what if that guy fired and hit one of
those cops this to me is
they would be prosecuting him you know
he'd be investigating him
you know what it is it's very very
simple she's not human dude
listen these people mess with the seat
of power
the trump supporters went to the
democrats home
business home in in these other places
it's on the streets on a highway in
portland it's outside a police
association building
a federal courthouse yeah the democrats
don't work there
well i'm still part of the seat of power
for that locality in that region
but it wasn't like they went to pelosi's
office right so all this is symbolic
which means it's
bull means it doesn't have any resonance
in fact
there's no equality under the law
anymore there's none
they're not even prosecuting or
investigating the only person who was
murdered was ashley babbitt
all those other deaths have been ruled
not homicides they're not even
prosecuting anybody
and they're not even prosecuting they're
holding people in solitary confinement
23 hours a day people have been charged
with trespassing and some people are
being beaten by the by the guards
there's been reports like one guy was
brutally beaten and he's got like broken
eye sockets look if you want to really
get in on details on this there's one
julie kelly
check her out she has been following all
this she's been tracking all the court
cases we talked about having her come on
my podcast
check her out julie kelly she's doing
great work hi julie by the way
so what is this guy's a federal cop so
they're not he's not getting this
he's capitol hill police i mean i don't
know why they're not investing i mean
the only reason they're not investing in
because
maga patriots are not human exactly well
obviously
yeah everyone's darker yeah but it's i
mean you look at how the media
you know i'll put it this way though
super dark i i am still kind of
optimistic for a few reasons right
i talked about the media's collapse the
rise of independent platforms like
substance
one of the projects ian spearheading now
is uh i don't know we should come up
with a name for it yeah
metanet i don't know metanette do you
come up with that no we're talking about
that on a call
the idea he's gonna say because like if
you don't have that trademark or the
domain bot yeah like you don't say on
air that you want to
do it's an open source project free form
everyone wins
with the domain the goal is to create an
open source
program that can create a subscription
platform for everybody that networks
with other platforms so
no one can be banned anymore your own
website but this is going to
decentralize the internet
and strip away a lot of the power from
the narrative machine
i take a look at cnn when we google
search riot and we get all this
mainstream news about the capital but
nothing about minnesota
and then we got one super chat that
figured it out for us
you needed to search for peaceful
protest oh my gosh that's brilliant
yes we did so we searched riot and got
capital and we searched peaceful protest
and it was like minnesota protest
peaceful protest mike elliott
and so i i think about this oh that's
interesting
at what point do people stop watching
cnn
because they're not getting news anymore
let me put it this way i saw a popular
youtuber
i won't say their name very progressive
and they posted about
donald trump for their like main segment
and i was like dude
it's it's april 14th and
there's riots the derek chauvin trial is
in full swing and coming to an end there
is so much
rich news to pump into the veins
of an unsuspecting populist instead
they're like donald trump
so i'm thinking this you know a lot of
people
were asking the question what will we do
after trump
i remember news news outlets were
talking about it and i remember people
asked me that they were like
well i mean you talk politics all day
like what are you going to do when
trump's gone i'll be like bro
there's other things last year i was
talking about science the hedgehog yeah
i was talking about sonic hedgehogs
and and birds of prey and how the
non-woke fun kids movie was way more
entertaining
i was like i got everything to talk
about because i care about news not
politics now that trump's out we got so
much to talk
about chauvin trial riot's arrests yet
how are these
these news outlets like cnn and these
progressive youtubers
still making segments about trump at a
certain point they're going to be
trapped in the past
and i imagine regular people are going
to be watching and they're gonna be like
hey i heard about this thing that
happened in detroit and the guy's gonna
be like yeah yeah but anyway donald
trump and they're gonna be like dude
trump's not president for months
why are you still talking about this
they're going to chase trump into
irrelevancy
and i'm i'm all for it how many how many
of these progressive youtubers
actually just made their whole entire
career
out of trump right that's all they know
that's all their clicks all their views
everything comes from that they're not
well-rounded people
that's the grift baby right so like i
came up
out of this little niche in the internet
called the manosphere but i was able to
break out of that because not only was i
capable of talking about those issues
but i have like a well-rounded
background of education experience
knowledge education
i'm happy and easy to talk about all
kinds of stuff so i don't know
knowledge you know what i value more
than my ferrari knowledge
books how you like dem apples by the way
julie kelly also from chicago i was
going to say well with a name like julie
kelly i assume her uncles are on the
police department
yeah you continue so no it's like
they're just going to be exposed for
being one note people
one no people one no people and those
people are gonna die all of you guys out
there still making the same company
we're all gonna die that you made in
2014
you gotta evolve how boring is that life
anyway i'm i feel bad for those people
i feel bad for the people that are still
talking about trump still talking about
dating mating still talk about that one
thing that got you attention
yeah over and over i mean it's it's like
it's like being bananarama
and having to go play that one damn song
look look at look at cnn that's exactly
it
look at look cnn is a great example all
right so ratings are starting to improve
for a lot of people
where we had this period after the
inauguration where ratings started to go
down because people are like okay i'm
done it's over
now interest is starting to come back in
a variety of stories and a lot of people
are reporting on like youtube and
podcasts ratings are starting to come
back it's a good day but cnn's ratings
are still going down oh no
look at uh look at reliable sources i
love that name reliable sources okay
the best they they they had this whole
thing where throughout the trump
presidency they talked about the
right-wing media ecosystem and
it's fueling trump and it worked as a
media show because
it was trump's narrative networks these
these various outlets that were propping
up trump
now that trump isn't president it's just
one guy saying like i watched fox news
yesterday
and tucker pissed me off and i'm just
like i don't care
yeah i don't care what tucker said that
you don't like because he's not the
president
he's not fueling a president joe biden
is the president
but when your whole grift is built upon
ragging on right-wing media
once they lose relevance he has nothing
to pivot to what's he going to do
the new york times announced that they
were forming the the tech division was
forming a union
oh yeah people are going to watch that
right but that really happened i mean
who cares though
nobody cares so he's trying to milk
desperately
like tucker carlson is the new trump
remember when brian salter said that
no he said tucker carlson sounds a lot
like trump doesn't he you wish
and people are just like they're begging
for a new trump we wish trump was more
like tucker yes fair enough
fair enough they don't have anything to
offer i i feel like i i get more
enjoyment reading some news articles and
then talking to you guys about it
than watching it on tv and being told
about it but i think a lot of people
don't have a friend
that they can talk to about politics
that's why we're here exactly thank you
for being my friend jack
i mean my pleasure sir my pleasure
the illinois boys will always be a
friend to you i lived in chicago for
three
hey hold on i was born no i was actually
born in chicago so i have my
i have my citizenship whenever whenever
i'm talking to people and they're like
no no i'm not
we're from the same neighborhood yeah so
tim and i yeah yeah we're
we're probably there around the same
time i'd imagine yeah we left when i was
pretty little but we were right but can
i say well i'm older
yeah we were right by midway yeah yeah
and i'm a bit older than you so
i was definitely a little kid and you
were still around god i am grandpa over
here
when whenever i talked uh and also uh i
don't know if i should i should say this
was a very prominent very very famous
progressive who lived like two blocks
away from me this is really crazy
but uh whenever i ask people like where
are you from this is chicago
i'll be like oh me too where where are
you from let's say naperville mm-hmm for
those aren't familiar it's like what 40
or 50.
like i'm from iowa yeah it's like
that's hilarious dude i decided what
said someone say that to me i was like
oh what part and they're like rockford
rockford exactly so like three hours
away no
no it was like an hour to two hours but
to be fair like so i actually grew up in
the suburbs we left the city when i was
pretty low but not naperville not that
far away
i mean i will never have to say i'm from
naperville it's a big place there's no
question about it yeah yeah and like
to be fair what are you supposed to say
i'm from naperville where no one knows
where that is chicago no it's also true
yeah so i just tell people the philly
area because we were in the jersey side
so it's not literally physically i know
like chicago
the first time i went to do your show in
philly right i'm driving up to philly i
get a hotel in philly and then i like
put in the address to go to your house
oh my god
places new jersey it's 10 minutes from
downtown
it was 10 minutes from downtown that's
the thing it's literally you're downtown
you cross the bridge you're there i
don't
know but what am i supposed to say to
people so i i'm from southern new jersey
dude
i'm not from there no one's going to our
show is there sorry sorry
so anyway the media is is garbage which
brings me to to uh our next amazing
story
i would like to give i would i would
like to all the people who are watching
right now
silently in your home start clapping for
james o'keefe just you know because he
he this is this is maybe one of the
biggest and best stories i think he's
done
probably not true i'm probably
forgetting something more impactful but
uh project veritas
has gotten a cnn staffer on the record
gloating
about covid deaths propping up their
ratings oh boy and he says
the red phone rings and it's jeff sucker
who i believe is the president
calling and saying hey get that death
tracker on the tv
because it's good for the ratings that's
amazing
that's horrible it's amazing but is it
really a shocker yeah
well hold on hold on hold on what's the
shocking part the first
expose that veritas did the other day
where the guys like we hate trump we
want we got him out of office we're
propaganda i'm like
oh surprise surprise we know this but
still good job on veritas getting this
information definitely but when the guys
on camera being here's what he said
quote
covid gangbusters with writings right
which is why we constantly have the
death toll on the side
that made my jaw hit the floor yeah i
didn't i i knew the bar was low for cnn
but come on
he's on a date with a woman going like
gangbusters mancovid all these people
dying
that's great wow that that that to me
was like
his first what's awesome is the context
if you think about it right
so this guy is on a date exactly
with a girl that swiped on him or
somehow got connected with him
uh well you know we don't know how they
met uh and they're on a date
and he's bragging to her he's bragging
to her about how they're making are you
imaginating the country please tell me
this was the first date too you like
take your lap for a first date you're
like guess what we're doing
bro hold on hold on first of all not not
the propaganda okay
imagine it's the first date and he goes
when people die
it's great it's like i make so much
money
right but you know the sad part is is he
probably doesn't get a single extra
penny based on
on ratings yeah and he's doing it
because he's a corporate drone
and he's selling out his country and all
of his fellow countrymen
so that some corporation and
shareholders can get rich which makes
him double triple loser oh my god
imagine going on a date with a woman
and trying and thinking you're going to
get laid by bragging about how dead
people are good for your good for money
well here's the other money
your first tip that this is a spy should
be that you work at cnn and she's going
on a date with you
like why on earth would anyone in their
right mind
the whole time he's like this girl she's
like she's really into me why is she
talking to me i don't know what it's
gonna go maybe it's because i'm worked
for cnn she must think that that's
amazing
is this woman's twit uh tinder profile
like you know people dying is exciting
to me
she's like i love being lied to he's
like perfect no
in the tinder profile it says i like
like adderall addicted
alcoholic balding fat guys that work
inside windowless rooms all day
that's what i'm looking for to be fair
this guy doesn't look like that
oh all right never mind that but but but
working for cnn puts you on that level i
think is what he's saying
sorry i was just thinking about working
at cnn takes you from like a ten to a
three yeah the reason why i take this
seriously is because there's been other
there's been other
uh verite veritas exposes where
employees of cnn were actually like
we used to do news this sucks we're
unhappy there was one guy he's like
sitting in a room with an older
middle-aged guy with a big old belly and
he's like we used to actually go out and
report stuff
and i when i saw that expose from
veritas i was like wait a minute
when was the last time you saw cnn do a
live report on the ground at a major
event
and at that point it was like deep in
the trump presidency i was like damn
it's been years yeah it's been years so
this guy's sad about it
this dude loves imagining the time of
his life
here's the best part though jack you
mentioned it he's not getting a single
extra penny right for cnn doing well
imagine being like randall from recess
you know like miss finster yeah he's all
happy and gloating like
human suffering makes my company succeed
it's like he's you're not benefiting
from it he just likes watching people
suffer
because it benefits his tribe that's
right and imagine think it's going to
get you laid i was thinking back
like where in my brain and how did it
get there that cnn had credibility
and i was trying to that was in there at
some point just just now i was
reflecting
on tim's comments and yes there was a
moment in my pre-awakened state
people are watching where man you don't
have to admit that
just stick around for the after show and
uh and so
i was like you know what it was it was
wolf blitzer during the first iraq war
i feel like that to me like anchored
credibility in my mind for cnn but
knowing what i know
now i look back and i just wonder how
much of all that was complete nonsense
in bs the whole time too yeah a lot of
that media first iraq war media was bull
yeah what i've heard from people that
actually served and fought over there
well there were there was this series of
papers that came out about afghan
these like afghanistan papers i've heard
about it which i'm not sure if you guys
have uh heard about these but yeah i
mean we were lied to from the start
wait hold on when was that was that 2010
or less
this was not as far as the afghan papers
were more recently yeah are you talking
about
did that come from that russian
psychological operator that guy
on the wiki the wikileaks
getting just dragged right now that's
not right
they gave him something worse than a
death sentence in my opinion julian
assange
he was exposing the establishment the
corrupt machine
he uh looked the emails that got that
got released through wikileaks
shined a light on what the dnc was doing
with these media organizations the the
nefarious uh double standards and all
this stuff
and for the for everything that julian
assange has done
they gave him something worse than a
death sentence it's a character
assassination
and an and indeterminate imprisonment
isolation isolation solitary confinement
with no timeline no hope
it's crazy dude the military industrial
complex is the empire from star wars and
if you ever watch star wars and think
what side would i be on would i be part
of the empire if you don't support
julian assange then you're part of the
empire
yep well to be fair we're all sitting in
the death star being like i hate the
death star i dislike this death star
it was so lame how the death star blew
up you know alderaan
miss ellis imagine being the next star
doing a broadcast show we were like
the decimation of alderaan was wrong and
protesting it and then like nothing
changes wait wait wait wait did you just
say
we're sitting inside the death star
right now yes we're part of the empire
yes i'm confused the the united states
government in the u.s
these forever wars yes and then finally
we get this act like accident like darth
vader accidentally loses an election
somehow he screws up
and then we get some crazy like you know
jabba
a hut guy yeah who's this you know crazy
yeah trump the trump humanist becomes
the the emperor somehow
and i'm like look the hutts are not good
people but this is better than darth
vader
sidious is out what do we do and then
the empire takes it back and then
and then trump the hutt was like i want
to do good deals
i want to make lots of money blowing up
alderaan isn't good for business
let's move let's do peace on tatooine
let's get our troops back
and then the the the imperials the
leadership were like no no we need to
blow up these planets
so you know then darth biden comes in
good old darth vader
get it get get the lights get get the
get the lightsaber rusty put it in a
barrel
well speaking of the industrial military
complex and they're lackeys in the media
it's interesting how
cnn and some of these other outlets have
characterized biden extending the
deadline for when we leave afghanistan
so biden says that as a non-negotiable
we're going to be out of afghanistan by
september 11th
oh and they're reporting it as if he
just came in and decided we're gonna
pull our troops out of afghanistan
no trump negotiated a deal with the
taliban where we were supposed to be out
by may 1st so biden extended the
deadline
and they're reporting on it as if biden
just came in and pulled us out ahead of
time and a lot of it is is negative too
they're saying things like well biden is
doing this against the advice
of foreign policy experts of course we
should stay there lindsey graham
he's like he's making a uh he's gonna
make another 911.
okay this is as bad as the 100 million
vaccinations in a hundred days story
you know where like biden comes in he's
like i'm we're gonna change everything
we're doing around here we're gonna do a
hundred million vaccines
in a hundred days which was exactly yeah
trump yeah but now they're just screwing
it up now it's like he's going to say
we're going to do 50 million they're
pushing through well that's the thing
so here there has not been a single
american troop
killed in afghanistan in a year at this
point but the taliban have said if we
are not out by that may 1st deadline
that we negotiated they will start
attacking the united states and our nato
allies again
here's my prediction come like may 3rd
or 4th
there's going to be an attack on an
american base and biden's going to be
alike
we have to stay it's clear that they're
not you know willing to allow peace
there's going to be a series of news
about attacks that's exactly what i was
thinking deadline's going to
so the choreography is in place the
dancers are prepped
yep the music is playing and the guys at
lockheed martin are just going like this
trump had to yeah to fight the foreign
policy establishment to get us to the
point where we could have a deal
negotiated
where in the near future we'd have all
of our troops withdrawn is completely
out the window and we're going to stay
over there
i think the ceo of lockheed is a woman
yes jack
did i just hold that's pretty messed up
so let me just say the
women who run the military industrial
complex jumped up onto their desks and
started square dancing together and
doing a jig and they're all celebrating
and clapping along i would say they
pulled up their skirts but no they
weren't
can't suit james
ceo and president he corrected you never
well i want to say like i really hope
we're wrong about this too but i i
basically made the exact same prediction
yeah i mean if the
taliban promised they would attack if
we're there past may first as in two
weeks from now
and we're saying we're gonna stay there
longer you will you will
sweet we're staying together yeah i
promise
why did they say september 10th anyway
they're obviously trying to make a
statement yeah so no september 11th yeah
that's what he said we're going to be
out there on the 20
like right after and then right on queue
lindsey graham pops up and he's like joe
biden's making a big mistake with this
republicans have to rally together to
keep the war going forever
and then joe biden's going gonna be like
you know we gotta have compromise come
on man the republicans you know we we
can't just
take whatever we want i'm gonna
compromise okay lindsay you're right
we're not gonna applaud afghanistan
because we we believe in negotiating
yeah that was like three seconds when
lindsey graham had credibility
during the kavanaugh tribe yeah yeah and
that was just gone
yeah i love his quote was that the
decision was dumber
than dirt and devilishly dangerous which
is
very nice remember yeah that cringy meme
where he was like walking like a
gangster
and he looked at everyone was like oh i
couldn't stand it i thought he was great
alcoholism in his eyes i was like this
guy's
so lame and like the kids want a hero
you know that these are my feet
oh i couldn't stand it i can't stand
that guy what a piece of the republican
party
got to play the republican party got
support
because they were forced in the trump
direction
exactly exactly the american people
rejected us no when the republican party
voted for donald trump they were
rejecting
the foreign policy establishment well i
mean they were rejecting hillary clinton
right but when his movement
actual support from americans who were
going to his rallies and showing up for
him a lot of that
was people who were conservative and
were sick of the foreign policy
establishment running the show
yep he beat 17 of those
a-holes it was a very clear state trump
the hut
yeah i like that metaphor that he was
like a hut because he was like
definitely
this gangster from outside trade dealing
you know doing deals
business the huts are bad people arguing
and they're big nasty and fat and all
that stuff
but they weren't they weren't like
they're not the sith no they're not
force sensitive
they were they were they were people who
were dancing around and enjoying their
time along with them
and a lot of people were willing to do
business with business with them and
think about how even
uh uh luke skywalker approached jabba he
was like i'll give you a chance
so even the approach to the huts or to
jabba specifically was like
you know maybe we'll make a deal with
with like the sith it's like
you know obi-wan draws the lightsaber
immediately he's like i'm going to kill
anakin now that he says he's a sith a
guy i've known my whole life who's like
my brother must die
the moment he says he's a sith it's very
very different you know what i mean
now that we're doing star wars memes we
should just ask leia what she thought
yeah
yeah i have her time with the hutts how
long
was she there chained up do we know
that's a good question how long between
the end of empire in the beginning
everything
no no because she goes there in the
beginning of the movie and then gets
caught she's
in the disguise remember that's right
yeah and then he captures her and she's
only there for a little bit i think
but between when han got frozen in
carbonite and luke goes to
to to jabba that there was like a year
or more
had passed so who's luke in this analogy
i don't even know i
do you do definitely not no you're
obviously yeah look at the hair no it's
gotta be like the son of a prominent
democrat who goes rogue and then like
tulsi gabbard man no i'm han solo like
i love it all right all right all right
should we talk about she goes
[Laughter]
apparently he was supposed to say
something like i love you too but
harrison ford was like han wouldn't say
that no so he's like i know
that was good that was good that's
classic there's something we got we got
game 101 for you timmy
we gotta talk about california guys we
got we gotta talk about california okay
okay uh so going over here in the in the
conversation
about being a chimpanzee full of snakes
right you know there's an interesting
idea that emerges about
uh um
50 snakes in the chimpanzee in 12 leave
how many snakes
fox news reports california promotes
dismantling racism and mathematics
guidance in draft for statewide
statewide framework
the concept quote the concept of
mathematics being purely objective
is unequivocally false document states
which you point that that's funny
because that itself
isn't unequivocal yes it is so she says
the concept of mathematics being purely
objective is unequivocally false and
teaching it is even less so
it goes on to say the document goes on
to say upholding the idea
that there are always right and always
wrong answers perpetuate
objectivity as well as fear of open
conflict
previous statement unequivocally false
following statement we can't say there's
objective truth that's ridiculous are
they going to put this to a vote
yeah oh yeah right so they're going to
count up the numbers and they're
like this unequivocally says that it's
we're in favor of this well hold on yeah
math math it's not let's objective these
ideas have been around for a long time
and i think people just don't realize it
the two plus two plus
well yeah i don't know like yeah just
being bad at math is a normal thing it
happens
no no the purposeful destruct
deconstruction of math when i was
younger i had friends
who were going to these schools where
they were learning this trash i remember
arguing with a friend of mine
when i said we were having an argument
or discussion and i said something like
the only absolute there's like nothing's
absolute i guess math except except math
i guess
and then my friend was like that's not
true math is an absolute and i was like
well okay
as far as we can tell math is like our
understanding of the universe and like
for the most part we believe it to be
absolute in many ways there are probably
variables but i guess
and then she's like no like how do you
know two plus two is four
and i was like because if i take two
pens and then two more pens there will
be four pens
and i got into an argument about
semantics deconstruction this is when i
was like 16.
so these ideas have been around for a
long time yeah and they've been getting
worse
especially with colleges they're
literally telling people it's on twitter
two plus two equals five
it's insane well here's the thing the
system of mathematics which tells us
that two plus two is four is what allows
for the science to be done
to build this kind of thing and the
camera i'm looking at the microphone i'm
talking into
and which is what allows for the people
watching at home to have access to this
conversation
there is an empirical basis for what we
are talking about here with the rules
and laws of mathematics
the alternate i mean first of all there
is no proposed altered system or
alternate system they just want to
deconstruct what we have now
it's completely ridiculous they have
nothing they're holding an empty sec the
whole point is i can point out that
you're incorrect
but again when they say things like
nothing is objectively true including
mathematics
they're making an objective statement
they're doing it so that
dumb people will be sitting down and
you'll say something like
in order to build a bridge we need you
know this math and they'll go you're
dumb that's not even true math isn't
even real
and then the bridge collapses wasn't
there a story about like a bunch of
feminists who built the bridge and it
collapsed
or something no i mean i don't know it
was it was like a
it was like a girl's school or like all
girls architecture engineering
i think it did happen i don't know all i
know is that when it's time to get paid
and someone is like you know i work two
hours this year i worked two hours that
day
that's four hours bro and if your
employer was like no it's just three
yeah it's the stock it depends on how so
this is the thing logic is real
yes i agree but math is calculated in
base 10 in our culture for the most part
so
two plus two does equal four but if
you're on a base three
two plus two equals one is on a base
three i don't know well
computers binary what if they're on base
orange
where their math is based on different
kinds of fruit that's not what if what
if they're on what if they're on base
gender and math is not numbers but
genders
do they really think in second grade
they're like by the way base three
we're now in base three guys r2 is one
your argument is predicated upon someone
else having different parameters that
could exist in any place based on
language
is a language it's not it's a way to
describe
consonants no no no no no and the
different bases you use is a different
language
right and in you're wrong what math
math is not a language we have an
english version of math
what if i said undertoi those are
different words a different language
you're still in base 10
but i'm describing mathematical concepts
using different words
i can say flork glop blebo and they
could represent
one two three they're just words to
represent mathematical concepts but
base ten and base two are different
languages to describe
this the same concept
so computers understand one plus one
equals one zero
the point is they are working binary
there are no twos in in computer
language well we all know that one zero
represents two
so it's obviously a concept of that two
represents in its own higher positions
actually this is a really great
representation of constructivism versus
objective reality
we're arguing that most people operating
in good faith
understand what you mean we say two plus
two is four your argument ian is
constructivist where you're like well i
can change the definition without
telling you
to subvert the argument i can use a
different language to give you a
different that no one changes changes
and the point i was making earlier which
is basically the point jack made when
he's bringing up your paycheck
is it's really easy to over abstract
these things and go well usually when i
see math
just on a paper and i'm told that these
rules exist but i can't actually be
certain
but when you look at what following
these rules produces in the real world
it becomes very clear that math is an
objective reality
right well when people say like how are
we going to communicate with alien
species
there's there's like two different ways
math and music
no bullets they come to my planet
they're catching nine men
but it's important to put this in
greater context right the same people
that are saying that two plus two is
five are the same people they're saying
that objective reality is white
supremacy that data is white supremacy
that being on time is white supremacy
that uh being self-reliant is white
supremacy that everything in america is
white supremacy and the united nations
just today our rep to the united nations
said that our constitution is steeped in
white supremacy
well when they say math is white
supremacy that's like
they're they're going salty they're
going minority root it's like one thing
to be like your culture is white
supremacy you have an argument about it
it's nothing to be like meth itself
objective reality yes i think the
concept of zero was invented
or discovered in like i don't know 200
bc or something it was
amazing yeah actually i always was
talking it was
the mayans the mines discovered it but
they were not the first we we found that
they had also discovered it which was
very
the discovery of zero own with no
influence interesting the discovery is
so hot
exactly if they're discovering zero in
two different
locations totally isolated by time and
space
without any communication well which
isn't that crazy or also
maybe it's universal all these cultures
independent of one another have an
understanding of there being two sexes
what am i saying so i think the up
one point i wanna make is that two plus
two equals one one
in base three but it doesn't equal
eleven the one one
you might read that as 11 but it's not
11. it's a different language
in base orange two plus two equals base
one two three four five six seven eight
nine and i
created my approach well and and i
created my own system called called
what you're missing is the analog you
can do you can translate that
mathematically so right with binary like
one zero one is
five but that that translates to
something one is one but then one
zero is two one one is three and it's
not a hundred and one that's ingenuous
how many how many shotgun shells are
sitting in front of me right one zero
in binary and what does that represent
well two in base two or more oh so it's
the exact same thing no matter what
you're calling it i'm gonna call it
floorbow
flump the the wizard i use the word too
because that's the language i'm
comfortable with right
i'm not a computer a computer wouldn't
be able to tell you that that's true one
zero and two are the same well
it might but one binary machine wouldn't
be able to tell you that
what you need to understand ian is that
you're talking about the exact same
thing and using different words
different languages no the way you're
failing hold on i
my turn all right i'm sorry jack they'll
we have to pass around
we have to pass around an old style for
the illinois voice and whoever has it
gets to talk
slits perfect uh what you're doing
is translating half of it without
translating the answer
and that's disingenuous if you're going
to start talking in a different base
then do it all on that base and then
completely translate it back to base 10.
then we'll see they're precisely the
same what you did in your example
sir is that you translated the first two
parts of the equation but didn't
translate the answer
and you left it looking inward two plus
two equals four they're doing the same
thing hold on
let's simplify this ian what is this
thing right here in front of me you know
you're saying hold on what is this thing
in front of a 45 apc
i don't know you're wrong it's a
distance you're wrong you're wrong it's
copper you're wrong it's a cartridge
it's all of the above
well you're wrong because ian seems to
think that this object is a bullet it's
actually a cartridge it's the same thing
it's a different word to describe the
same thing
so if it's two plus two does equal four
saying two plus two equal five
makes no sense that is wrong and there's
two does not equal five at any base
right so i know exactly that's the point
no that the argument they have is that
if you have two point four you round
down attack that's not two oh well
that's
that's the argument really they make is
yes two point four plus two point four
is four plus eight
two point four round if you round is two
so you'd get four
but if you add them together then you'd
round up and get five that's like common
core math
what they're doing is they're changing
the parameters that no one asked for to
create their own answers
the point of which is to deconstruct
your world view and trick you into being
their servant
exactly okay then that i think maybe
there's in city
insidiousness too what what these people
are talking about but i also do believe
getting lost in base 10 and thinking
that the world exists in base 10 is
dangerous
i'm so hardcore fine with base dude base
10 is what i'm all about because i've
got 10 people they call me base 10
coughlin man that's my nickname
look just because you know and like say
it in different languages doesn't mean
you're not all looking at the sky
it doesn't mean that the sky is
different you're just speaking different
language and that's all the different
bases are
don't let anyone get confused just a
different language to describe the very
same reality two plus two equals five in
a language where five means four and
four means five how about that boom done
zone
one two three five four six seven eight
i can't get down with two plus two
equals five
it sounds so silly saying that two point
four is not two so exactly i think
fundamentally we we agree yeah yeah and
math is racist
it's just racism
there is objective math but it is racist
okay yeah i mean look there's another
the accelerationist in me that says go
ahead
no yeah no go ahead let them teach them
that let's see what happens
and there will be there will be so this
is the way feminism is going to end
is when a younger generation looks up at
the older generation and says i want
nothing to do with that life i don't
want to be crazy at margaret i don't
want to be 55
with cats and no kids wishing i had a
husband and a family
and lamenting the fact that i decided to
really pursue
that hr job where i got up to second
senior assistant vice president
the same thing could happen in these
circumstances unfortunately it's sad
that these kids are pawns
exactly these kids these kids will grow
up not knowing math
not being employed and then the kids
behind them will be like yo teach me
the math now hold on hold on i know that
it's
silly to talk about how math is racist
but let's talk about something that is
object a lot of people might be going
like i don't understand their argument
in the first place
let's i want to give some okay hold on
let me slow down you tell someone math
is racist that's what they genuinely
believe and a lot of people are going to
be like
huh but let me show you something this
next story we have it's culture story
that should be able to be shown to any
regular person to convince them
this critical race theory is racist
and insane my friends i give you one of
the funniest stories i've seen in a long
time yes
from the rap idris elba's luther was
quote
not black enough to be real bbc's
chief diversity officer says the uk cop
doesn't have any black friends
he doesn't eat any caribbean food
miranda whalen says during an industry
conference
wow that's the most racist thing the
bbc's chief diversity offer said idris
elba doesn't eat enough caribbean food
to be actually black
now you want to tell me what's racist
whoa that yeah
it just alba's great i just you guys in
the dark tower no but i read it
i thought it was great it's incredible i
mean dude i saw the wire that's all i
need to know
oh my god he's i'm not he's the star
right
sorry shape sheamus i'm i apologize
sir i'm offending my friend sheamus
idris elba
is amazing on the wire well i got to
tell you according to beep the bbc he
isn't black enough to play luther
here's what they say quote when luther
first came out everybody loved the fact
that idris elba was in there
a really strong black character lead
miranda whalen said on monday
during a conversation on bbc's diversity
and inclusion strategy
at the digital miptv conference we all
fell in love with him
who didn't right but after you got into
about the second series
you got kind of like okay he doesn't
have any black friends he doesn't eat
any caribbean food this doesn't feel
authentic
this is the most amazing thing in the
world like there
there was this meme that said sexism
is when a man says to the woman go do
the dishes
equality is when the men and women both
say either one of us could do the dishes
and gender ideology is whoever does the
dishes is a woman
but it's true it's hilarious though it's
true now you look at this
their definition of what makes him
authentically black is that he's a
stereotype
idris elba's awesome he's he's uh
heimdall in the marvel cinematic
universe he did a great job i thought it
was he thought it was fun
he's he's in the dark tower he's in a
bunch of movies he's red
why why is he not authentically black
he's literally a black dude
this is the chief diversity officer
believing that what defines someone race
is the food they eat and their
stereotypes if joe biden was describing
him he would call him clean and
articulate and bright
like he did like he did to obama well
spoken yes
but no but well nowadays he would go
he goes he's clean and yeah can i rub
your legs
we've got hairy legs yeah but think
think about idris elba he's supposed to
be eating jerk chicken
apparently no joke like caribbean food
like what does she expect of him to be
authentic
crazy yeah it's real i quit eating
cabbages and potatoes boys am i still in
the club exactly
what about the corned beef all right oh
well i'll eat the corned beef okay then
you're still cooking i haven't had
bulgogi in a long time so i think i'm in
trouble
i think it's korean beef i must be i was
when you said that i was like
bro i don't remember that growing up
that's hilarious you certainly don't uh
yeah but you know what i'd i had some
irish food growing up too i get to i get
to i'm sorry to hear it
you guys aren't allowed to because it
would be racist it's racist to uh to
partake in other cultures apparently
and everyone is defined by the
stereotypes they engage in so
i guess for me that means i have to be
drunk cause i'm part irish i have to use
chopsticks and eat bulgogi
and uh what what are the stereotypes am
i forced to be a policeman you must have
to be a cop and but be a cop on the roof
with a gun
yes that's how that's what defines me
well the third one you gotta unlock dude
almost i can get on the roof right over
there apparently idris elba responded
to weyland's uh claim that he doesn't
have any black friends so therefore
isn't black enough by saying on
instagram we must not pull ourselves
backwards
only push ourselves forward that's so
stupid he's not black because you don't
have
that is like the most extreme version of
you are the five people you hang out the
most with
like your race is not a product of who
you're around you're well hold on
we all are part irish and we're all
friends with each other that proves
we're irish
and honestly i was just going to say i'm
doing the math here and math is racist
[Laughter]
wait hold on carry the one yeah
we all have irish in our dna and here we
are so all friends that proves it
that means that we're only irish and
nothing else where's that whiskey yet
i got a big thing of proper 12. oh i'm
on it i love that well it's not such a
big thing anymore tim i'm not going to
lie to you
all right fine what is it like well
you've got you've got about half a shot
left
yeah oh you guys drank no bottles i
drank i
i'm allowed to drink it because i'm part
japanese and irish but not you guys i'm
not drinking because you're my friend
yeah no no i don't give any abortion i
thought i got that i give you no i
don't get permission to appropriate my
culture yeah
come on no you're appropriating my
culture you can't do it you guys can
have that
also are you implying that we're not his
friends wait wait hold on because we
can't drink it
ian's like all right i get that these
guys can't have them like i'm your
friend
who's allowed to drink the tyler here
right who's allowed to drink the tequila
hail to life i love mexicans what's
wrong
who's wrong pirates that's idris elba's
drink
what do you guys have a favorite liquor
i don't like any of it it's all gross
i like i like whiskey i i do like a good
bourbon too though
that sort of comes in i do not
discriminate i like them all in
moderation at the right time with the
right foods
that's the exact balance do you have one
lady oh yeah i actually do i really like
whiskey and i like tequila
in small and i actually yeah you know
the other night style there
you were giving me a heck of a hard time
on twitter and then and then all of a
sudden you're like nah it's all good i
had a whiskey
yeah i have an idea you know what we
should do because we we're we're
preparing to do
live events here the goal is like every
friday wait wait
you got don't qualify that because i was
already getting blown up here by people
saying that tim cast irl is not live
additional live events additional live
events they think the show isn't live
yeah correct it's with a 10 second delay
they're about oh whatever well youtube
youtube has an automatic delay but what
makes them think it's not live i have no
idea because i took a picture at seven
o'clock of us in the studio
oh show the show the show is literally
live right now literally and we have the
super chit's going and we just we just
wait till the end of the show to read
them
but uh we're gonna be doing live music
venue events nice so on fridays the goal
is when we wrap up the show around 10 we
throw the camera to the venue which
we're putting up
and then have a performance of some sort
comedy maybe like a political
lecture kind of bit routine maybe music
and uh you know it'd be fun we could do
uh uh um
everyone who's involved in organizing it
can produce their stereotypical food of
choice
i know everybody here is irish i guess
so you guys just bring a bottle of
whiskey so not food yeah
you don't want our food you'll take our
alcohol beers and whiskeys
guinness and mashed potatoes cabbage
i just by the way i checked twitter when
you mentioned that because i did see
that people were claiming that tim cast
irl is not actually live
and i did notice when i mentioned
someone tweeted an article that the
democrats
and i just verified it on google um the
democrats have
uh the house and senate democrats are
planning a bill to add four justices to
the supreme court this one's broke
yep yeah wow whoa that's a whole topic
do we
because every time you're like i'm
pulling up this this amazing article
everybody and you push the button
all the viewers get to see it and i'm
like yeah use your magic where is it
where
is
it where is it we have that tv over
there we just don't turn it on anymore
yeah we don't we suck
all right we'll get a tv in here we'll
put it over there like
something yeah we can put it up there
and up there i don't know if they can go
in the ceiling like that
plugged in maybe they can but hey here's
the thing actually we did just prove
your point because if this was
filmed before it was aired we would be
able to talk but we would never have
been able to talk
unless we can see the future that's a
whole other level of conspiracy there
that's amazing
well you know the great thing about this
bill that's being proposed is that
they're only going to phase these new
justices in like once every 10 years
right it's going to be oh i'm sure it's
going to take four decades
i just got to be honest with everybody
okay i can't we can't get the shred
going on uh
the show isn't live it's actually
recorded recorded after it airs
so it goes it airs at eight pm and then
we come into the zoo at ten after it
airs
it records the show and then we use we
use a rotating beam of light
with a with a micro singularity to send
the data
back bro we're gonna that's the whole
ian secrets come on that's why that's
the literally the whole reason they have
not been able to cancel us yet and you
just gave it away
but it is why it's so cause we film it
later exactly
they haven't been able to pin down our
location and like shut down the stream
like where's these guys
we watched the show in the past live at
the same time as everyone else and then
record it afterwards and send it back in
time
is this sliders did i get this one
confused again that's the time travel
that's the dimensional channel read the
software code we might as well now
because everyone knows yeah seriously
that's their secret
so we have i had this idea um for what
we should do and it's that at the end of
every episode
we wait like 30 seconds and then we play
a clip where it's like ian waking up in
the middle of the woods
and then like various things happen
where he's like smoking something with
his shaman
with them and they're like how was it
this time and ian's like dude
i'm going to give you like the joke is
that this show is an astral projection
of like an e
of the of ian tripping which basically
is i mean yeah basically
i mean you're you're always tripping on
dmt because it's coursing through all of
our veins
that's how i feel when i'm talking to
you
back to the house democrats no i mean
this is remember when joe biden refused
to answer the question on whether he
would stack the courts that's
interesting
dude i'm i'm stoked if they do it it'd
be awesome oh my god yeah
i hope we get i hope we get another rg
no no no just like
just you know you get to you get to tell
your friends you were right you know
what i mean
it's like it's like that's what's most
important about having a country
television
i just want to be able to be like i was
right this time you see i've been saying
that tim you're right all the time
i'm kidding were they going to stick
forward before democratically approved
no i'm sure justices you know i'm sure
they're going to be justice who
because that's how many justices they
need to get the majority oh
clever weird what a weird coincidence
right so what is it six to three d-o-a
oh wait but they have the senate
right never mind so they would have
everything and then joe biden's gonna be
like come on man you know guns should be
banned because
you know ever since second amendment
some people weren't allowed to have guns
those were slaves
no constitutional amendment is absolute
that's right joe biden which is crazy
because i think some of them are
definitely supposed to be absolute i
think they would acknowledge that 13th
amendment what about the first amendment
what about
you can't yell fire in a crowded theater
so we can yeah joe biden said
since the second amendment there were
always people who weren't allowed to
have guns
which is a direct reference to slaves
and the indigenous
interesting so if you're literally
referencing people who are slaves or who
are
in having their land colonized and being
conquered
it sounds like you're making an argument
for why we need guns
exactly or an argument why to make more
slaves exactly it makes it sound much
more sinister doesn't it
that took a dark turn well look i mean
you can do whatever you want to an
unarmed population
true you watch this video to the uk
where they kick someone's door in
because
he violated like coveted lockdown no
yeah the
i'm sorry sheamus i'm really being
shamed here uh
when the guys looking down the stairs
and they break in the door and they they
come oh my gosh
and they're like so what people
understand is the left is often like
they're like do you think you're really
going to fight with the government and
win
no no i think the police just have to
make sure they have a warrant because
the constitution says you need a warrant
and they need to understand that in the
case of brenna taylor when they did have
a warrant
and they did knock still one of the cops
still got shot and it was ruled
justified
that brianna tells his boyfriend shot a
cop they said you can't you kick
someone's house and it's on it
it's reasonable for someone to fire at
the entrance absolutely so it's not
about wanting to go to war it's about
the government being like
hey we can't just barge into someone's
house at random because they have a
second and fourth amendment right that's
gonna that's
that's bad news for us or how about this
like it does yes the second amendment
was there to allow the people to revolt
against the government if that ever
became necessary but how about
i should be able to protect my family i
should be able to use whatever weapon i
see fit to protect
my family because i have a duty to do so
and therefore i have a right to have
access to what will allow me to carry
that duty out
yeah second amendment is literally about
defending so
so i want to make this clear i hear from
a lot of people the second amendment is
about the americans fighting a
tyrannical government
that's not true some people say the
second amendment is about hunting that's
that's literally not true second
amendment is
partially about defending this country
from tyrannical government
but the second amendment doesn't say
that it says
necessitating a free state which means
foreign and domestic
the right to keep and bear arms could
also mean that
canada could invade the united states
and we need to be able to protect
ourselves and i think they're planning
it
there was there was a war in which it
was the war of 1812 where the u.s
invaded canada and almost took montreal
gosh darn it that's right it ended up
with the white house getting burned down
so that didn't work out too well
yeah the first one i guess what happened
was we were like you want to go to war
with us we'll take canada
and then they were like all right we'll
just burn down your capital then because
like you're gone
great and they did that and then they're
like hey what if everybody in the
country had guns
that would be a lot easier well we did
have the second amendment i know i know
but it wasn't nearly as widespread we
only had one amendment at that time and
they're like we're gonna add a second
right gun ownership has exploded even in
the last few decades it's incredible
what's happened the way the gun
ownership has exploded up
at the same time the gun related deaths
and mass shootings have been going down
now did you see what happened with the
washington post the other day
they put out a study that said that the
white supremacy attacks or whatever had
been escalating escalating escalating
and they actually
had changed the definition of what a
white supremacy white dominance
you know act of terror or whatever was
they changed it from actually
killing somebody doing a crime to a
credible
threat found on a message board wow
no i swear to god to be fair that is but
to be fair jack
a threat on a message board or a
threatening message on the the message
board is terrorism so but this is really
important story uh
john robb on twitter uh a a tremendous
analyst who you everyone should be
following he pointed this out he dug
into the study
and when you look at the actual numbers
for white supremacy terror attacks or
whatever
they've been they peaked guess in what
year 2016
and guess what happened since then boom
boom boom boom boom
down i'd also be curiou i'm also curious
to see how that's defined as well
well interesting sure but the point is
is that the washington post twisted the
definitions around
they showed that there was a huge
increase in these white supremacy
attacks and then the very next day
it's been cited by all the politicians
and all the people saying that we need
new laws we need to
crack down on the insurrectionists and
detrompify america and detrompify the
military
yada yada yada all with cooked bs
statistics yeah it's manipulation lies
the deception what else is new for these
news outlets
well you hear this garbage you hear this
garbage all the time oh all of these
mass shootings are carried out by
white men i mean the numbers i'm looking
at right here are white
people and it's almost always men mass
shootings are basically never carried
out by women but
white people carry out 66 percent of the
mass shootings the country's like 72
percent white
so they're undead so we're
under-represented but even so how are
they defining massachusetts that's true
too right because if you define messages
because
three people being injured which some
stats do okay in dc there's a mass
shooting every day
exactly based on the based on the
criteria usually that three people being
injured with a gun they need to just
give everybody in dc guns
well no one can it's very difficult i'm
not saying it's
impossible it is very difficult to get a
gun in dc
you literally have to order it through
the police department wow
you and you can't you you have to order
it from out of state it has to be sent
to the police department at 300 c street
or whatever it is
you go down there you pick up the gun
from the cops
after they've already done all the
background and written down all the
serial numbers and all the things
it's very difficult process i can't wait
to get to maryland
well that's not a great state for
firearms but uh it's better than dc
it's better than dz let's take some
super chats my friends if you have not
already smash that like button and
comment because you're basically telling
youtube you like the show and you re we
really appreciate it
so uh seriously smash it but go to
timcast.com become a member
now we just switched over this week to
the new site and we are still in the
process of of
going through it that's that's that's
that's the
it's the best way to do it right you
just have to do it we got to figure out
where the holes are and fix them as fast
as possible so
we're working on getting everything
streamlined we have a couple people that
are going to be joining
soon producing news articles and special
interests like
uh paranormal weird ufo kind of articles
as well because we're gonna be launching
that show
very very soon it's a process it takes
time unfortunately but uh the website's
gonna be awesome
members are gonna get access to all of
this really cool stuff we're just keep
making more and more stuff it's gonna be
fantastic
we've got we filmed an episode of the
vlog the grind bar has been grown
that video will be up soon as we're
working out the kinks for the new
channel so go to dimcast.com become a
member
don't forget to subscribe because we're
gonna break a million subs soon let's
read these super chats
jonathan nefor's ah this first super
chat i am proud to say we have proven
wrong
he said tonight on quote tim mentions a
star trek episode that applies to the
topic
it was star wars yes the star trek was
on though downstairs
of course of course it was tng is always
on it is when i when i watched
this house we watched i walked in there
was no one in the house
there was no one on the first floor and
the only thing
that was happening was data blowing up
at like 95 inches 4k
smoking a pipe oh waxing philosophically
as if you were a human home
and then jack just got hooked and sat
down and watched the whole episode yeah
i'll get a coffee and get lost in it
from across the room four lights there's
four lights
one or four lights there you go it's
just a crazy fantasy and then patrick
stewart walks on and it's like
epic yeah epic all right we got trip
sucks he says
jack i teach science at a private school
private middle school in ca
what can i do to push back against the
woke teachers with seniority who are
pushing their agenda on our program
it's a very difficult question and i
think the first thing to do
is to make sure that you understand when
and you have leverage and when you don't
don't just stick your head up and start
screaming about stuff because you get
your head chopped off
you have to find yourself in a position
where you actually have a moment to make
change yelling about things isn't going
to help speaking up at the staff you
know all staff meeting isn't going to
help
you have to get yourself on the
committees you have to get yourself on
the curriculum committees and you have
to
actively derail what they're doing but
subtly
what if what if you accuse them of being
racist doesn't matter
yeah they don't care no they don't care
they don't care because they'll just
turn it right back around on you there's
there's no way out of their kafka traps
that's the thing you can't you can't
argue your way out of it you can't
emotion or logic your way out of it
you have to actually consider yourself
to be an undercover agent
and you are on a secret mission and you
have to wait until you have leverage to
actually
make change otherwise you're just
suiciding yourself
and please don't do that all right we
got preston jenna says i've noticed your
subs have been going up consistently
about 1k
or so a day for the last few days hope
you guys hit a million on this channel
tonight or tomorrow congrats and great
work we are
371 subscribers away from one million
subscribers
it should be by late tonight or early
tomorrow and uh
i mean it's it's whatever it people
watch they watch it's it's appreciated
it's it's it's
it's a metric we get a gold we get a
gold uh plaque and then we'll put it up
on the wall and it'll be great and you
guys are awesome we appreciate it so
much
it might be in the next five minutes if
you guys subscribe that's true
here's the thing yes i mean subscribe to
tim but also like i'm way further from a
million than he is
so i actually need your subscribers more
if they just want to go to youtube.com
freedom soon see some cool cartoons drop
a little sub in there for me thanks
slash jack murphy live new videos every
day
which you can do you could i guess do
that if you wanted
long-form videos every week all right we
got
uh dermy wormy says i recently became a
member of the site and this is for
two of my favorite guests my friends
this is the illinois boys
dale and always boys correct so this
this happened because
sheamus was here jack was here there's a
couple weeks ago and we had portillo's
hot dogs which are
from chicago and so then i think sheamus
made a joke about the illinois boys
right no it was it was actually
um right before the election when i
first met jack he came on one of the
shows and we were just
making small talk and he's like yeah i'm
from x area i won't dox you i won't say
which area of chicago i was like what
beverly
yeah beverly and i was like wait tim and
jack and me and we have uh so i was like
we are the illinois
boys yes now on our own each of us
individually is an illinois boy but
together
is the illinois boys
dude here's the thing we have been
talking forever like since we all first
met like oh yeah we should do an episode
with the illinois boys
and there's this weird thing where i
don't think we talked about that on air
but i will regularly like when i see my
name mention alongside tim cast and i
see like a compliment like oh i really
like sheamus
and jack martin like they i we have been
lumped together in a weird way where
people like oh sheamus is my favorite
guest ever and then like
jack murphy's also okay but i will no i
will actually but i will actually see
that where like people who like one of
us like the other ones i think
both of you are some of the most
consistent guests we have oh that makes
sense so they just see our faces but
otherwise
you know there's nothing very funny is
it like he is the pretty one
exactly like bring the noise illinois
boys bring the noise that's right
exactly indeed they do
hashtag yellow noise
tn says it is telling me to fix my shirt
let me let me
fix it yeah yeah you forgot you should
probably pop the collar yeah man why
didn't you have your collar pop the
whole time dude
i don't know looks good though i feel
bad you should wouldn't be able to see
disaster it's like disastrous that's a
great coordination nobody's watching
them
all right all right we got uh christian
but if you are watching please
please subscribe to my channel nobody's
watching this channel that i'm siphoning
subs off of right now
good work everyone siphoned it all right
christian jamgochian says tim why do you
keep talking about the second amendment
when discussing state-level gun laws
state laws only have to follow the
state's constitutions and the us
constitution only restricts the feds
except for something called what the
supremacy clause yeah the u.s
constitution supersedes the states
if the u.s constitution says shall not
be infringed the states aren't supposed
to be able to
infringe but clauses in the in the
federal
constitution so how should someone else
be like you have to follow my laws
and i have a clause that says you have
to follow my laws because they signed
my own law they signed up to join me
union
bro yeah sorry sheamus were you about to
say by the way
it was infringed anyway i'm sorry
there's this is the the
shall not uh be infringed is infringed
all over the place come come to my town
uh and and ah man the case just shooshed
right out of my head i can't remember
the name of the dc case
the handgun case that changed the law in
dc anyway hello thank you there you go
thank you well done next next orion nero
says if chauvin is acquitted of all
charges how bad do you believe they will
riot
my opinion um they'll be okay
it'll be it'll be nationwide it'll be in
every small town the big cities of
course will see the worst rides they've
ever seen
and a lot of the small towns which
already had riots which don't know about
because the news and report it
will see substantially worse riots as
well
yeah i can get on board
i think people are going to respond
really reasonably this time tim and it's
all going to be fine
they're going to sit down in the street
and sing like hallelujah yeah
kumbaya hallelujah by what's it what
who's that
yes but not his version right he wrote
the original lyrics
most of the time when you hear it you
know what's going to be interesting to
see how the normal people respond
in may of last year when people were
rioting it was very easy for the
normal people to be like well they
really hate trump
yeah these rioters really hate trump
trump is a nazi
i understand why they're rioting okay
guess what trump is gone
biden is the president this is now still
gonna happen they're rioting against
what now
now they're not just rioting against
trump now they're rioting against
america
yeah and that's the way it needs to be
framed these
riots are not anti-trump riots
they are anti-america riots and when are
people going to finally stand up and
protect
its outright insurrection at this point
it is it is it is it is
uh um getting hot yeah decentralized
groups that share an ideology
attacking institutions of government
across the country for over a year and
you know what the the really important
thing here is
we're 122 subscribers away from one
million
subscribers all right people hit that
like button right now let's get up to a
million how many likes but you can't
subscribe
that like button well the like i meant
it tim it'll boost us in the algorithm
and more people will see and subscribe
that wasn't
three buttons that we need to hit right
now guys there's three buttons you need
to hit four or five buttons it's just
like these republicans making it more
difficult to vote very complicated
you are so close
[Laughter]
no i was just going to say you're
absolutely correct that that's the way
the media needs the framers should frame
it but of course they're not going to
and these
these are people who are still trying to
talk about trump even though he's out of
office and they want to talk about trump
ism so maybe that's what the protest is
against i don't know
it's going to be systemically racist for
sure that's going to be the the whole
talking point this time i think it's a
protest against the empire i mean okay
it's a it's a mixed
it's a mixed convoluted system that
we've got going on and there is a
military-industrial complex
in a banking establishment i was going
to say they're really protesting the fed
is what they're doing yes okay we got we
i'm sorry guys super chats are very
important yeah sorry so we have a very
very serious one
that i'm i gotta take seriously uh
charlie in charge says
i am no longer a gorilla i now identify
as a chimpanzee full of snakes
well here's the thing it doesn't matter
how you identify that's what you were
going along like your identity is a
product of a negotiation with the
society around you you don't get to just
like how about
that out of thin air man how about we
make a shirt that says i am a chimpanzee
full of snakes yes
that's my
[Laughter]
i know jordan peterson will come sue me
my god it's full of snakes
i am a chimpanzee does anybody get that
reference no no what is that snake's not
a plane
that's 2001. oh my god snakes odyssey
2001
i'm sorry sorry
oh great work everyone i'm like i shoot
i'm like nine for 10 on jokes on this
show
last time i was here i dropped a dad
joke and like literally the room just
went
both sides
[Music]
steven voiceover says loving the jp
impression let's hear tim and jack's
attempts at it
keep up the good work guys you have to
try oh and big love to ian and liz
don't ever stop tim lest the beanie
become a has beanie
we're over a million subscribers
[Applause]
i was here when it happened i'm not
saying i'm not saying that i am
responsible for you
can you be respected but i was
definitely here yeah we're actually
183 subs over millions oh what happened
fast
the illinois boys were here at the time
you went over a million subs that's all
i'm saying
do we hold do we link arms and sing now
like yeah we hold hands do i call google
and say i want the
overnight i want that golden black
overnight no good that's
you mean three golden plaques one for
each illinois boy and i guess i guess
five
i guess five is like lydia and ian have
kind of banned i mean i kind of like
yeah
tim says i should have it i think i
should have it you know what i'll do you
can actually order multiples
because it's like if you have a team of
people working on the show it's not fair
to have one so like you can you can tell
them you get one for you gotta buy the
rest
i'll buy a bunch and we'll build a fort
out of it yes
and that's the whole podcast from
that'll be the next video like a hall of
mirrors
wherever you look
i think you need to really show
appreciation for your fans by making one
for each subscriber because they are the
ones who yeah right
that was a million of those that would
cost like 300 million dollars
i'm sorry are your fans not worth it are
the people in the campaign
are the people who supported you hold on
hold on i'm curious
i don't know if there's a limit on how
many i could buy i'm like i got 50
employees so i want 50.
i don't have 50 employees but then could
you just sell them for like a premium oh
i'll sign it and send it to you i don't
think you arbitrage i'm just wondering
like there's rules against well here's
the thing if you tell people there's
only one
but then you sell like 12. oh my god
this is the
limited edition tim pool million
subscribers signed
play signed woman you just make a bunch
dude it's signed by sheamus instead of
me
no it's here's what you do you sign a
bunch of them and that's just how you
monetize your channel from now on if
youtube comes and shuts you down you'll
just sell two of those a month for it
everybody thinks they have the only one
here's the thing it's marked one out of
one i hope they never forget each other
all right all right let's see what we
got here congratulations tim
congratulations by the way
by the way we should congratulate you
tim tim is one of the hardest working
dudes i've ever met in my whole life
this guy grinds like crazy he's been at
it for years and years and you deserve
everything that you got buddy
man yeah we got so much more coming we
just filmed the vlog we had this pro uh
biker mike feedy came out and he did a
feeble grind on his bike
he actually did a gap to people on the
bar in the va like he grinded on the bar
right we he grunted it and we we filmed
it we're going to put this vlog and uh
you know i want to let everybody know
like we're looking for ideas to do to
have fun events here so
send uh uh i guess spin the ufo you're
tracking that's still right
spin the ufo gmail.com for ideas and uh
mike he made a youtube video saying like
i'm your guy i'm gonna come out and do a
tail whip and he did he did it till what
he also
did he like did a wall ride back and
forth it was legit
from the mini ramp riding on the walls
of my basement was awesome whoa
so like we're we're gonna i think we're
gonna have a scooter a pro scooter like
i don't know if he's a pro but we're
gonna have like a
high like a really talented scooter guy
come out just pay him
he's a pro we'll see i mean it depends
on what they do i suppose but we're
no we're going to have we're going to
film videos with a bunch of uh different
i guess action sport disciplines
but we're looking for musicians
comedians and you know all different
types because we're going to be treating
like a venue probably every friday night
having someone come out
film a vlog of some sort and then we'll
do something with the live show or
be fun all right let's see
should i read this one ben andering says
tim i want to let you know that there
there is a peeling happening with
diamond hand shirt i have had two shirts
with defects i sent an email with
subject urgent gorilla shirt
peeling yesterday um bummer
i mean it's it's it's teespring but uh i
think
we'll we'll reach out to them and try
and figure out if we can see if there's
anything happening
because the ones we have we've actually
been really happy with so i don't know
if there's been a bad batch
we did have a misprinting issue at one
point so
you know what with the black hands yeah
no the white hands yeah i'm down to
experiment with different companies
because if they're not washing properly
oh this is interesting scott gosnell
says mr poole have been trying to reach
you about your
car's extended warranty whoa they got
you you should answer that one
there was a funny meme where was like if
i see you broken down on the side of the
road you think i'm gonna help
i'm going to help you you've been called
about your car's extended warranty
and you could have taken yeah so many
times the message in a bottle
oh yeah your car is extending one
every day why is that that people are
getting phone calls about yeah it's
called scam likely it's my best friend
they call me every day
scam good friend yeah
student of history says the issue is the
da was an activist and jumped before 100
investigation because the race hustlers
and commies immediately began blm
national sport
sport the ludathon and now call and now
call is
guilty and riot not guilty riot harder
rip cities keep your rifle by your side
okay i did not track that one let's see
uh rebel media was suspended by youtube
did you guys hear that oh no but i know
those guys yeah who is that
ezra canadian fellow wolf star
says tim has become way too biased the
state is winning and he won't tell his
audience
anyone remember the 49 state claim it's
happening again this one i really like
because on wikipedia the activist
the wikipedia is a smear machine and
they really tried hard to include that i
claimed repeatedly that trump would win
in a four dance landslide
and then when someone posted the quote
they were like it sounds like he's just
saying
in the event things happen there's
speculation of what would cause a
fortnite state landslide as opposed to
saying
there would be definitively one so like
the issue was me like
obviously being hyperbolic or
exaggerating like if these riots don't
stop
you know and then you know joe biden
does this or that man 49 state landslide
and it was like often many of these were
like memes where like the trump
supporter would just yell trump
landslide
and it's a meme representing trump
winning not a literal landslide
but uh sure however saying that the
state is winning
it it's it's it's like it's a moot point
it's an argument of over whether or not
you
think that the state's witnesses are
credible the issue is
when you read mainstream news they'll
say state pro state
prosecution's witness says chauvin was
not supposed to do this chauvin killed
floyd
chauvin is responsible and it was
negligent in between that it's
on cross-examination the defense said
well it's entirely possible chauvin did
receive training to do this on
cross-examination it's entirely possible
that floyd died for other reasons and i
would even even have concluded as such
in in potentially certain other
potential circumstances
the state wins when they prove beyond a
reasonable doubt two things
george floyd was killed by chauvin and
chauvin intended to kill him
oh i'm sorry and chauvin was uh uh
was not trained to do what he was what
he was doing it was outside of the
purview of his
of his job so that's actually three
things now manslaughter is
that chauvin killed him and it was
negligent
so in for the second degree murder
charge like i just don't see how that's
possible
and and most people thought it was an
overcharge anyway so
if you only read the mainstream media
that's what you probably believe
will rudman says police are in in place
to protect protesters from americans who
are done with their nonsense police
leave and americans will step in
okay well the americans voted against
the police so i'm not sure i agree with
that statement i get it but
you know if the people of minneapolis
voted for joe biden and kamal harris
who are supporting the riots then why
should the cops be there to support
people who don't like them i don't
understand that
paul luckett said crowder made some
points with the female cop in the video
you can see that her partner gets
between her and the suspect
while she is aiming her gun directly at
him she almost shot her partner
this isn't adequate training absolutely
i agree with crying that 100
uh i think you know um phoenix
ammunition mentioned this on twitter
there's no such thing as an accidental
discharge only a negligent discharge i
agree
it's crazy to me like i think if you're
a gun owner that you know what i keep
hearing over and over again from
everyone who owns guns you are
responsible for what comes out of your
gun
100 period yeah period 100 yep from any
person
anybody else yourself any time yes right
it's your response whether you're in a
different country or anything
yep yes that's why you buy gun saves
that's why you
you know you keep you keep track of
what's going on and
if you're holding that weapon that's why
you have to follow all the rules and
understand how to be safe
and if this cop was given a gun and she
accidentally shot if she pulls her out
accidentally
it wasn't an accidental shooting it was
her pointing a gun at somebody and then
shooting him
yeah it wasn't it wasn't it wasn't
murder but
all right museum says jack you are wrong
about ashley
she got her hands and knee up on the
busted window in the door and was
attempting to go through the window and
then was shot
they released a video recently showing
it happened plain as day
that is a justified shooting to you brah
no thank you a woman had her head in the
window so i shot and killed her
nice try release the craggle says i got
a hard question what's your favorite ice
cream
you can't just ask something like that
these are the kinds of tough questions
that the biden administration
is getting from reporters and i
shouldn't be held into that kind of
scrutiny
probably chocolate probably chocolate
chip cookie dough butternut
cashew ice cream i saw this really great
flavor from ben and jerry's called
cookies and crime
yeah the daily wire posted a photo of it
it's a riot i think it was the daily
it's a riot yeah so that's not what it
is nobody said that yeah
i said just i don't know ice cream with
cashews in it i mean the ice cream is
made out of cashew milk
cashew cream so creamy
and then i really like milk and cookies
from ben jerry's yeah you like ben
jerry's
i mean yeah you still could still eat in
that dish no no
no no no i'm not eating that garbage i
have this new thing it's from a company
called
uh boo foods like bhu foods oh those are
so good dude dude
yes eat like two a day at least the
protein bars yes this is this is
is is you know what you know like i
often make the joke that ice cream is
evil
because like you're eating all this fat
and sugar and just so bad for you
and so it's like the joke is it's so
good but it's so bad right
that's a joke yeah we have these these
cookie dough jars it's actually just
cashew butter
but it's flavored with chocolate chips
and it's they use monk fruit and cherry
cherry juice so it's really low sugar
we have these protein bars dude it's
better than ice cream dude if you guys
want to average you had something what
do you think you thought it was good i
thought it was really good i almost ate
all of it
i will talk about your product every
night on this show
if you guys want to advertise with us
please do because oh come on come on now
that's how you ask for us we are not we
are not doing a problem this channel has
a
million
dollars you need to take this more
seriously a million
dollars dude it's so good it's vegan
it's vegan gluten-free it's crazy
and it's like it's like basically just
cashew butter but it's it's like whipped
and it tastes like cookie dough i keep
one in my room
so i don't need to eat ice cream anymore
because we got this really good healthy
stuff that's what it's all about it's
probably
how did you find those they got an
instagram ad for it wow and then i and
then i
ordered i ordered like two of each and
then they got eaten in like 10 minutes
by everybody banana chips you can scoop
it yeah
oh yeah see see i want to be legit we're
not paid to sponsor anyone
i just wanna i wanna like shout out
things i like and if we can work as with
sponsorships it's like even a bonus
all right let's see steven chomper says
tim good news biden's gun control is
completely constitutional
the second amendment has fine print
about about a free state that we are no
longer uh
we are no longer in a free state so we
are good to infringe on those rights lol
yeah i tweeted the uh the uh you know
well-regulated michela
a well-regulated militia being necessary
you know to protect the three state or
whatever there's a moment bro the right
to keep and bear arms shall not be
infringed
unless you don't have a permit from the
government are not old enough
can't pay a tax or don't have a valid
state approved reason
oh tim i i've gotten to know you pretty
well over the last year i mean
and you know we met each other well
that's like four or five years ago but
now at the deplorable
and i got to tell you i am as perplexed
as ever by your current twitter feed
which one all of your tweets i read them
and i'm like
this one this one's sarcasm this one's
trolling this one's legit
i can't tell anything i can't tell
anymore there are people who think
twitter is life
and so someone tweeted what's the point
of being a commentator if no one knows
what you're saying and i'm like well if
you watch my show you do if you're on
twitter that's your life
you're wasting your time right that's
kind of the point indeed
no but like what which tweet are you
referring to the one
all of them all of them i read them now
because some a couple of them have
caught me
you know like is he being legit with
this is being straight
so now i just read them all with sort of
like a blank face where i'm like i don't
know what he means but i'm just i'm just
rolling with it
i think i think this is actually by
intent my intention though i said i said
lock the cop up who shot dante right
i couldn't tell if it was if it was true
or not i couldn't the point is
if a bunch of people are screaming we're
going to arrest all of the police and
destroy them and burn them alive
and the cop is standing there going like
yeah i'm with these people then i'm like
okay
okay you go to jail now if the so
minneapolis is a house on fire
where chauvin is being these these these
three other cops were charged with
aiding and abetting
like can you believe that that's how
that's insane and so
they're in us they're they're so they're
being abused they're being mistreated
they're being smeared and they're not
all perfect there's there's needs for
police reform and the system needs
reform i get that
and then i'm like we're gonna fight
we're gonna resist and we're gonna we're
gonna call this out
then the people of this state this in
the city vote in
democrats and vote for those who
supported the riots
at that point i'm like all right the
fire department like you were you you
had a house on fire
and everyone voted for the fire
department that supported the fire
in which case i'm now going to ask all
of these cops to maybe get out of the
building
because there's not much we can do at
this point and this cop said nah i'm
with the fire
and i was like okay all right when the
house burns down what do you want to do
gone yeah when your car breaks down
you've been called about your car's
extended warranty you expect me to come
help you
my point is i feel like it's like a
vocal it's not a minority but like
it's a vocal crowd of people that voted
the idiocy and now the other people
like the cops that didn't vote for it
are suffering
and and forced to deal with these these
mayors and governors that
aren't supporting them at a certain
point
when your house is on fire and you can't
save it you have to leave
the building oh yeah you can't sit there
thinking like i'm gonna keep spraying
water and you know and the house
collapses on you and i'm like bro i
can't rush into a burning building to
save at this point
so if you've been warned over and over
again and the people who are who set the
fire are laughing at you
watching the place burn to the ground
and you're like don't worry i'll do nah
i'm sorry sometimes houses become so
dangerous that the fire department will
just burn them down
they'll light the fire and burn it down
on purpose because it's too much of a
danger to leave standing
all right let's read some more super
chats diana stoian says my cousin and i
have been watching you for a few years
now she's one of the smartest coolest
humans it's her birthday month please
wish claudia
stoian a happy birthday happy birthday
claudia happy birthday claudia
happy birthday sam b says you have to
have a reason to switch bases we count
in base 10
because we have 10 fingers and don't
count with our toes you switch to base e
in certain engineering applications
because you're counting with the euler's
number
wow interesting mathematics sam b says
jack and tim have it right
whatever you do in base two if you
consistently do it through base two then
switch to base ten
you'll get the same result as if you did
it in base ten and vice versa
that's right the confusion is when i was
one one and you don't know if it's a one
one or an eleven
i'm confused when someone says you know
undertoi and i'm like i don't know what
those are math doesn't exist to me in
other languages
it doesn't exist anymore oh no dose
trace that's clearly different they
represent totally different
dose quattro tim uno dos cuatro no it's
uh uh
uno dos tres cinco cuatro
all right let's see um wazapalooza the
drunk says yo tim do you remember when
uh elbow was up for the spot of james
bond i was ready i wanted to see it but
they said nah
yeah i guess people were mad they were
like why would james bond be
you know black or whatever and i'm like
because james i thought james bond was
like
i thought like was it what they say was
like a code name or something
also i don't care i guess i think isabel
was cool
i don't know they changed the actor and
they like this is the weirdest thing to
me
he would have been an awesome james bond
yes yeah absolutely uh my thing is like
actors can act
i'm not i'm not i don't really care
about you know though people are mad
that mary antoinette is being played by
a black
woman and i'm like struggling accurately
like even if it's a woman
who was it john reese davies he played a
dwarf yeah that guy's tall isn't he
oh that guy was awesome no he played a
dwarf in the lord you know he's crazy
but like
and they used it
are you sure but that dude with a beard
was definitely definitely a wizard
definitely a witch i think i feel like
gandalf
saruman what about yeah he had that guy
definitely definitely all right we got
waffles sensei says congratulations on
the one million
subs tim you deserve it keep it up take
care of yourself keep it real like mary
poppins and fly that arrow with your
heart
was it no no i'm sorry wasn't it yondu
udanta flew the arrow with his heart
yeah he sure did who's that
yondu yeah
he's trying to explain to peter quill
how to use the energy from ego
the planet and he's like you think when
i use this arrow i'm
using my head you gotta use your heart
any whistles in the air goes
dude that movie is great brent newark
says mathematician here
ian stop pretending that you're an
authority on math you have no idea what
you're talking about
sketch proof four exists in base three
okay wow t let ft
z be mapping f n equals three n
stars i will not this is this is a
genius
but you must speak to me on my level
this boundary this is a bijection
f1 colon z arrow t exists
f n plus m is isomorphic to z
i'm just going to go ahead and assume
he's right because he posted a bunch of
letters that's racism
i'm confused so it's obviously racist
yeah it's obviously racist it's math
math numbers that's racism right 100
percent 100 of the time
wait oh no 100 20
of the time there you go 100 there we go
100 ish you're open
yeah good safe all right we'll do uh
we'll do a couple more super chats here
and then we're going to go to that
members only exclusively
that's awesome a lot of people saying
congratulations on the one million thank
you guys so much
thank you tim cast irl has cracked one
because of you i see this mostly as jack
and i's achievement
same and now that i'm experiencing this
like live i'm
no longer motivated to reach it what's
the point yeah we got we already got the
doubles this is
this is important can i just say
something tim just got up to 100 million
we could do my channel tonight 1 million
1 million we could do 100 million too
let's get we we could get my channel up
to a million tonight so go over to
freedom too just subscribe right now
hit that smash that subscribe button get
us up there
megan stewart says wait is there a
safety on the cop's gun
because how would she not know it was a
gun if she'd take off the safety
glock blocks don't have safety safeties
facts don't care about your glock who
was i talking to i said give them a
break
feelings military they got safeties on
them
and then what would happen is she would
have drawn the wrong gun and it would
have went yeah
about that yeah i still wonder if she
was telling the other cop to tase and
then it didn't happen so she unloaded
them she'd probably
argue that i think the police made a
statement she'll say i didn't say that
but i i i never liked that when i you
know i got a glock and i was just like
so no safety and they're like no they
claim it's got a pressure safety like
you got
you really pull the trigger yeah i get
out of here
no i should have a safety on it well i i
get it you know whatever
um maybe they should have safeties and
and i think
phil was talking about this too he was
like if you're properly trained a safety
isn't
an inhibitor for properly drawing it
doesn't slow you down at all and she
would have been like oh wow whoops and
she would have you know
what about biometric safeties where you
need to scan your thumb print on it we
are so not there yet no they exist you
know
what wait that we could just give to all
poli we think we have the money that
that technology is accessible enough
that we could give all the police in the
country so if someone steals your gun
they can't
i mean i'm sorry for writing you off ian
i
and the other issue i think the reason
they don't use it is the the way the
holsters are designed
you can't pull the whole stride unless
you're at a proper angle and you you
press
in a certain way so it's kind of like
what's the point if the cop accidentally
shoots somebody they would the gun would
work no matter what
it would prevent someone from stealing
it i guess yeah there's a movie where
that happens we're selling it
there's a james bond movie i just
watched james bond all three of them
casino royale
quantum of solas and skyfall and
at the last scene it's about a guy with
a gun with the palm reader on it james
bond had it he got it stolen from the
guy tried to shoot him it was like click
click
and that was the end oh snaps all right
my friends here's what we're going to do
nh says please pair with jordan peterson
on the chimpanzee full of snakes shirt
of course figure that one out but my
friends
a lot of people have been mentioning
there's some issues with timcast.com as
we poured over the new site this
is to be expected it's one of the
reasons why it took so long to do
because we knew
as soon as we rolled it out we'd hit
bugs and then have to work to fix them
very very quickly because we're not a
massive billion dollar multinational
corporation
we're like a dozen people in a building
and trying to expand with your help so
go to timcast.com there that we're going
to be fixing everything and trying
getting things uh up and running better
and better and better
these are the growing pains we have to
go through i suppose but i appreciate
everybody who's a member because you're
making this possible
and we're going to record now a special
members only exclusive segment with lots
of swear words in it
wait what that'll be i didn't agree to
this oh yeah well
sheamus won't swear but uh go to tbs.com
sign up there's a big library of content
already tons of guests
and it will trust me we're working on
fixing everything so
we're gonna have this really cool
section where it breaks down categories
you're gonna be able to look in
the different topics so uh go check it
out don't forget to like share subscribe
to this show if you're listening on
itunes or spotify leave us a good review
you can follow me on all social media
platforms at tim cast
and my other youtube channels are
youtube.comcast and youtube.comcastnews
the show is live monday friday at 8 pm
so we will be back tomorrow
so now sheamus and jacket to fight over
who gets to shout out about it
you you go first because no you go the
last time exactly that's what i'm saying
you think a fellow illinois boys
wouldn't know
the rules murphy live is there a more
irish name than that
jack i would say sheamus coughlin jack
murphy
might be a little bit jacked live also
on twitter instagram facebook everything
all around the internet it's almost as
if i planned it that way
jack murphy live good to see you very
cool i forgot what i was going to say oh
my gosh
freedom tunes freedom tunes go to
youtube.com
freedom tunes that's o o
musical tunes freedom tunes subscribe we
have a cartoon coming out tomorrow we
had one that came out
yesterday so we're really cranking them
out yeah the episode that sheamus just
did with jordan peterson as the red
skull
is just insanely funny thank you it's
painfully funny we were laughing so hard
nonstop
thank you the problem is you laugh so
much you might miss one of the jokes so
you're like trying to stop laughing
watch it twice yeah watch it twice hulk
smash hulk smash
thank you i love you guys
[Laughter]
and you guys can follow me at ian
crossland.net at ian crossland all over
it's because of you
that this show is killing it right now
we've reached a million
subs thank you ian sheamus you are the
one i was talking to you guys are
amazing you are
amazing sheamus is actually the one uh
who taught ian to to astral project to
make the show
i would never teach him something like
that but i did but i did get a tweet um
just now congrats to tim cast ian cross
and sour bachelors jack murphy live and
most importantly sheamus coughlin
creating a million subscribers on
youtube thank you finally the
recognition i deserve
miguel de la cruz thank you that's right
wow that's how you get ready
thank you guys for tuning in tonight and
please join me in my quest to beat sour
patch
kids and followers on twitter at
sourpatchlids on twitter
by the way a word to the wise if your
shirts are peeling you may want to wash
them inside out
this apparently helps you maintain the
paint on the front
good to know we will see all of you and
the members on the
members only exclusive at timcast.com
thanks for hanging out and we will see
you there bye guys
you